Candid Truth.
>> What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth. We're going to
get candid with it. And right now, we
have to talk about what was going on
with the whole Charlie Kirk incident
because
everybody's talking about it and
everybody has a different angle going
on. And you know, I wanted to wait look
at a lot of evidence before I just
jumped on. I know a lot of people were
jumping on like the day of and the day
after. And I I've seen people have to
recant things that they said the day
before. And I I didn't want to fall into
that trap. I knew from the very
beginning that I was already seeing some
things that caught my attention because
anytime anytime a major
incident happens that's spread all over
the controlled propaganda mainstream
media news, I always my antennas always
go up. I'm always looking, always
analyzing and always skeptical that what
we're being shown is actually a real
event or uh where does is there some
kind of agenda behind what's happening?
How are they going to use this crisis?
These people have openly said um never
let a good crisis go to waste. You know,
these are the type of people who control
the world and so I'm always looking out
for those types of things. I got my
brother Jeremy Sorado here today. He's
going to help me uh balance me out a
little bit. No, what's up, man? Glad to
have you on here, bro.
>> Glad to be on.
>> Yeah. So, yeah. I mean, what did you
think when you first saw it? I know like
you you messaged me and then we kind of
were going back and forth, but I I've
had a lot of people reach out to me.
I've actually seen quite a few people
change their mind about what they
initially thought. And so that's why we
want to talk about this. We want to look
at a lot of the the evidence, the
details, and just the thing is I don't
ever want to turn a blind eye to
anything. I'm not going to just say,
"Oh, well, the news told me, so I
believe what the news said." I don't
think that, you know, we should feel bad
or guilty or shameful about looking at
the details. You know, anytime there's a
a court case or a murder or anything,
you're supposed to look at evidence and
try to find out who did it, what was the
motive, uh was this story real, was
somebody being set up, all these things.
Like, that was never looked at as a bad
thing in the past. But now, right,
you're supposed to just trust everything
that's fed to you from the the
mainstream media source.
>> Yeah, I agree. Yeah, I definitely
thought, you know, um actually it was
you that sent a a link to my wife and
she she forward it to me and I watched
that
and uh it it kind of changed my
perspective a little bit. Um, my initial
thoughts were, "Wow, this guy." Okay,
first of all, um, we had something like
this just happen with Trump. This is
just I mean, he was he was just
>> talking about the ear thing.
>> Yeah. Yeah. The ear thing. He was shot
at. It was is an assassination attempt.
>> And um, when I saw that, I think I was
maybe the only person that I could see
in my circle that was really questioning
the entire situation. And like you said,
when the
mainstream media pushes it, has a
specific agenda that they're moving in a
specific angle, you wonder what are they
trying to feed me right now? I don't
want to eat it.
>> Yeah.
>> And so you you kind of start questioning
things. And so I had some challenges
with that. And um but when Charlie when
it happened to Charlie I thought oh
that's this is terrible. That's hor
horrible horrible horrible. Um and you
know we're not trying to be insensitive
or anything like that. We're just trying
to look at the facts and we've got a lot
of information to share
>> and uh my initial thoughts were sh I was
shocked. I was completely shocked and
and I was brokenhearted too. And so you
go through a lot of those emotions when
you look uh at these characters, you
look at these characters, you look at
these individuals
and um you get connected to them because
you you have you have a similar it's
like they speak for you
>> in some so when they when they speak
you're you're like, "Yeah, yeah, give it
to them. Let them have it."
>> And it gets really emotional really
fast. We got to be careful.
>> Yeah. I'll admit I I never even knew who
Charlie Kirk was until this happened and
and then I started seeing what was going
on. But I guess um that might have
played out in my favor actually where I
didn't have any kind of attachment to
him.
>> Yeah. And you know like Ravi Zacharas
>> Yeah. Ravi Zacharias I loved when he
would go to colleges and just destroy
atheists and make them think rationally
and all that kind of stuff. And I did
have an attachment to him. I was like
this guy is awesome.
That was Charlie Kirk. Yeah.
>> A modern a modern Robbie Zachcharias. I
didn't have a connection to Robbie. So I
was like, "Okay, well, you know,
whatever." And then when he came out
having that challenge,
>> Yep. There was a sex scandal out there.
All these
>> he would go travel in any way.
>> Yeah. He would go travel as a man of God
and
>> and manipulate women into doing sexual
things with him
>> and and keeping it silent because it
would destroy his ministry and all this
stuff. And um we actually when I was on
Little Light, we did a show about it
because we were trying to figure out
like what do you do with this books that
are out there? These books that have
literally like put atheists in their
place where they had to change their
mind and think rationally and logically
that information is still valid no
matter whose mouth it comes from. And I
made the point, you know, even if Hitler
said
>> something true, it's still truth. you
know, we we'll often
>> like the Catholic Church and abortion,
you don't turn from that teaching
because it's true,
>> right?
So, that's kind of how we're setting
this up, I guess, is that
here's a person that many people looked
up to because he had a lot of good
points. He was uh, you know, shutting
down this
twisted woke wokeism mindset. But
something I've been saying a lot lately,
man,
>> Yeah. And something I've been saying a
lot lately with Trump because so many
people are all in support of Trump
because he's getting rid of wokeism and
he's doing all this stuff. And I'm like,
okay, those things are good, but you
have to understand that both sides, left
and right, Democrat, Republic, they're
both controlled by Satan. The the Bible
says
>> by the same puppet master.
>> Yeah. The Bible says Satan is the god of
this world. We battle not against flesh
and blood, but against principalities,
against the the rulers of the darkness
of this age. It it's all a show. The
thing is is all all the other countries,
they have dictators and stuff, and
people know that they're slaves, and
they end up having an uprising, and
America has been so strategic about it
to where, right,
>> um, it's just this pendulum effect. So
if you're conservative-minded, you get
your leader for four years. And as the
left is getting angry because they're
not getting their side, now it's voting
time. And oh, now you get yours. It's
always back and forth. Always
Republican, Democrat, Republic.
>> And there's truths on both sides.
There's also error on both sides. That's
why it's so easy for there to be this
dichotomy, this separation, this divide.
>> Yeah. So if you if you're a conspiracy
theorist at all and you do any kind of
research, you'll hear about something
called the Hegelian dialectic. You'll
hear about order out of chaos and the
and two steps forward, one step back.
All these things are what is what's
happening right now. We
were funneled into this chaos like
there's 86 genders. If you don't cut the
genitals off your child, your your kid's
going to be taken away. Every sane
person knew that that was wrong. So now
when Trump comes in and he's getting rid
of all that stuff, people are cheering
and applauding like he's doing something
great when really he's just bringing
back normal.
>> That's really nothing to be applauded.
>> That's it.
>> Yeah, he's bring bringing back normal
and at the same time uh still creeping
in the agenda. He's the one that right
when he came in said we're going to roll
out Stargate AI governance.
>> So is that something that we want to be
controlled by AI? You know
>> AI?
>> Yeah. So him and whoever was before him,
I can't even remember these guys
anymore, but the president before him
who was the Democrat, they all had the
same agendas. It was all um it was all
the medical care, the space travel
stuff, the AI stuff.
>> It's all the same. I mean, back
>> Exactly.
>> Yeah. Back when he was in, the
Republicans were like, "Oh, we don't
like Elon. He wants to microchip your
brain." And then all of a sudden, he's
Trump's right-hand man.
>> And then and then and then they were
pushing the microchips. They were
pushing all that same exact stuff on the
Republican conservative side.
>> Yep. There were articles that came out
and said, "Yeah, they're gonna push like
the the vaccines and all these these
things." And we said,
>> "What?"
>> And everybody's just like, "Cool.
>> Who are you gonna fool?" And then they
were like, "Cool. Awesome. My guy."
>> Yeah. Exactly.
>> It's like it's the same guy.
>> Yep.
>> It's that you won because now it's your
guy.
>> Exactly. So, I do want to start out by
saying
now that we've kind of laid that
foundation that both sides are puppets.
I don't trust anyone involved in
politics and I don't trust anyone that
has a huge platform. Whether it's
Hollywood, whether it's mainstream media
news, whether it's the music industry, I
don't trust those people because I know
what the Bible says that G that God
that Satan took Jesus to a high mountain
and said, "I'll give you all the
kingdoms of the world if you just bow to
me." This Satan is the god of this world
and he can offer you all those things.
Look, think about how many amazingly
talented people who are out there who
are never going to be anybody in the
limelight because they refuse to sign a
contract, right? And so it's the same
thing with politics or Hollywood or the
industry. I don't trust if you if you
have that big of a platform
automatically
I think you're a part of it. You're
you're on the inside club. You're
Freemason, whatever.
You you don't just get to those places
organically anymore. There might have
been a time where your
talent got you fame. There might have
been a time like that. But it doesn't
happen anymore. That's why you have all
these people who lack so much talent and
these mumble rappers and all this stuff
because it it's not about talent. It's
about agenda now. So with that said,
what people were really
excited about was that
Charlie Kirk inspired people to go to
church. I mean, this is all stuff that
happened after his death.
>> Yeah.
>> But people are saying
>> Charlie Kirk effect.
>> Yeah. The Charlie Kirk effect. I mean,
look at these comments. I I actually
screenshotted these comments.
>> I have a whole lot.
>> Oh, yeah. So, it's like, bro, the amount
of people saying they'll go to church
Sunday is inspiring. So, one thing I'm
hearing from Sabbathke keepers,
including Adventists and whoever else,
they're saying that they really look up
to this guy because he keeps the seventh
day Sabbath and he's promoting that. But
I'll be honest,
when I heard him talk about it, mostly
it had to do with time with family. I
mean, he said, "That's the day I shut my
phone off, you know, and his wife is
saying, "That's the time I get to see
him. He's not distracted by a million
texts and messages and emails and all
that stuff."
And uh the Sabbath is about family, but
it's mainly about God.
And so when this person says, "Bro, the
amount of people saying they'll be going
to church Sunday is inspiring."
I'm actually not seeing anything. I'm
not seeing any of these comments say,
"Wow, Charlie Kirk inspired me to keep
the seventh day Sabbath.
They inspired them to go to church on
Sunday." Uh, this next one says, "This
hit this hit hard. I'm admittedly an
alcoholic and substance abuse, all this
stuff. I felt sad, angry, devastated.
Um, something inside me changed for the
better. Two days sober now. I pray for
Charlie and his family. Life goes on,
but his name will live forever. Um,
>> yeah, this is a this is largely an
emotional experience with a lot of
people,
>> right? It happened during 911, right?
>> Go far.
>> When 911 happened, people were in the
churches. Um,
>> yeah. Yeah, that's right.
>> This this girl says, uh, I'm returning
back to church after 23 years. I
purchased my first Bible and I'm closer
to God today because of Charlie. Because
of Charlie. I get it. There are people
that inspire you. Like I have people in
my life who have walked with me through
my journey and my growth and everything.
Um and so if if Charlie something that
he said resonated with people and it's
inspiring them to read the Bible and go
to church, that's awesome. I do I I'm
thankful that people are actually giving
God a chance, reading his word, and
going to church.
Um, but that doesn't mean
that
that he's innocent or anything, you
know, because my thing is is is the the
Hegelian dialectic. Satan plays both
sides. It's good cop, bad cop. He he has
to in order to deceive the entire world.
It says that the dragon is going to
deceive the world. It doesn't say the
dragon's going to deceive the the
liberal left,
right? So, how can he deceive the
conservative right?
There's got to be a charismatic leader
that's really inspiring and everybody
looks up to him. Trump was one of those
already.
>> Yeah.
>> Right.
So, these are all just screenshots of
people saying they're going to church
after, you know, not going to church for
30 years, 10 years. I was an atheist. Me
and my husband are going to church after
a long time. I haven't been to church.
All these people are saying they haven't
been to church, but I keep seeing return
to church this Sunday.
>> Um, and and this last one says,
>> it's going to play into it.
>> Yeah, I'm going to church. I'm going to
the church first time with my husband
this Sunday to honor Charlie.
What about to grow spiritually or
>> wow to Yeah. You know, like to get
closer to God to honor Charlie. That's
not the right motive to go.
>> But you know what? I think I think that
is largely one of the major spirits that
is pushing that is that this is a a very
emotional experience emotional time for
everybody and it is a honoring of this
man really in many cases more than
honoring of God.
>> Yeah.
>> So we got to be super careful with that.
It says right here actually that um the
Google search for church is highest in
12 months right here. Oh wow. So people
are searching it. I mean this thing is
literally exploding worldwide.
>> Yeah. This has only been like a week if
that.
>> It's not even been a week I don't think.
Yeah.
>> Wow. Um this is the last page I think.
But it's like my husband and I have been
talking about going to church. You know
it's like all these people are saying
like you know what I haven't been in
church for a long time. I've been kind
of considering church, but this event is
going to make me go and and it's of
course it keeps saying Sunday and and
stuff. So,
>> yeah, you go on and on and on and on.
We've got a whole dozens and dozens and
dozens of of
posts from Twitter or X and and all
kinds of other things saying the same
things.
>> Yeah. And so, you and I believe the same
way prophetically. Um, we understand
that
there's going to come a a one world
government, a one world religion, it's
actually going to look a lot like
Christianity, it's going to look like
peace and love and, you know, it says
when he's when they say peace and
safety,
>> sudden destruction will come upon them.
You know, I grew up on movies like Left
Behind, and it always made this uh there
was always this one leader that was the
the ruler of the world, and he just
hated Christians. He was killing them in
the streets and stuff. That's really not
how it's going to be at all. That's not
deceptive. How's he going to deceive the
whole world by just killing anyone who
believes in the Bible or says, "Do you
believe in Jesus? Bam, you're dead."
That's not deceptive.
Satan's actually going to appear as
Christ. a supernatural being is going to
do lying signs and wonders, performing
miracles. And people, the Christian
church is just lost all discernment
about that. They think, "Oh, if it's a
miracle, it's got to be from God."
>> And can you imagine the emotional
>> response that that is going to bring?
>> Oh, dude, that's going to be crazy.
>> I mean, I mean, it's it's going to be
game over.
>> Satan is a master manipulator. And
that's why Jesus said when they said,
"What'll be the sign of your coming?"
And he says, "Look, when they say I'm in
the desert, don't go. When they say I'm
in the secret chamber, don't go." He's
saying, "Don't even look. Because if you
look, you will fall for it. There's no
way that you're going to overcome this
being face to face with a supernatural
being that's an angel of light that's
doing miracles."
>> What's that?
>> It's a magnetic pole. There's no way you
can resist it except for being under
Christ,
>> right? And and this is why it's so
important to, you know, some people are
like, well, let's not get into doctrinal
beliefs. Let's let's just agree. Let's
just talk about the things that we all
agree on. We believe in Jesus. That's
something good. But it's like when it
comes to the timing of the rapture,
let's not talk about that. Um what the
millennium is like or what happens when
you die. All these things are so so so
important. And yet people don't want to
talk about them because
>> it's uh it's triggering. But what
happens when you don't when you when you
think when you believe like you're gonna
there's a pre-trip rapture or you don't
understand that Jesus isn't going to
touch the ground.
>> Right. Right. The doc the the basic
doctrines on the second coming and these
different things like that. Not being
prepared for that. You're going to be
able you're going to fall.
>> Right.
>> And of course spiritualism and the state
of the dead and all this kind of stuff.
It's going to be big and it's and
everything's going to consolidate.
Everything is going to come to one truth
and we're going to have nothing to stand
on unless we have some understanding.
>> Yeah. Cuz he says, "I'm I'm coming like
lightning flashes from the east to the
west and the dead in Christ and the
righteous living will be caught up to
meet the Lord in the air." It doesn't
say, "I'm going to come down on earth
and I'm going to be beautiful and I'm
going to be doing miracles,
>> right? There's going to be a thousand
years of peace and then and then, oh,
here's these guys who are not allowing
us to have that peace. Look at these
guys over here.
>> He actually says you're gonna see cancel
culture and and all that. It's not going
to go away.
>> Yeah. And he actually says
>> be perfected.
>> I am not coming to bring peace but
division with a sword, you know. So it
it's it's just amazing that like you
said just these fundamental beliefs
about the second coming. So many people
don't understand those things that when
they see a supernatural being on earth
doing miracles, they're just going to
fall for it. Including us. like you and
I even knowing what we know. Knowledge
isn't Yeah. Knowledge isn't just enough
when you're face to face.
>> I I' I've been I've been telling our
audience on here that I'm more fearful
of the deception than I am the
persecution. I'll
>> torture me because I know I'm going to
have a crown of life. But Lord, help me
to not be deceived when I'm face to face
with a supernatural being and I have
feelings of love. And people think that
the devil can't do that. But
>> newagers feel love. Newagers talk to
Jesus. Newagers do healing. Reiki
healing and crystal healing and all this
stuff.
>> All those things are of the devil. And
yet people think if it feels good, it
must be right.
>> Yeah. Because emotions are very
powerful. And you're hitting on it right
now because that's what it's going to
be. And I think that's what it is now
with the Kirk effect and all this other
stuff. I think that people are very
emotionally they're they're being
brought in through emotion.
>> Yeah. And like again, we're not trying
to be insensitive because, you know,
there's a lot of people mourning and we
have respect for that. But that's what
we're seeing is that we're being brought
in through emotion and we're going to
continue seeing that when angels come
down.
>> Yeah.
>> And we start seeing we start hearing the
music that they're singing.
>> Oh, man.
>> It's going to be like, whoa. I mean,
it's going to it's going to
>> uh [__] us in emotional
love. I mean, it's going to be a
feeling, but it's going to be powerful.
More powerful than anything we ever
knew.
>> Goosebumps.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Goosebumps, tears, all that
kind of stuff. And we're going to run
for it. We're going to run straight to
it. Unless See, it's not about
knowledge. Like you said, at that point,
it's not knowledge.
>> Yeah.
>> If we are if we are That's why music can
be so dangerous because it bypasses the
frontal lobe,
>> right? Right?
>> So, you can't critically think and
analyze what is coming into your brain.
The music, it just comes straight in and
you're like,
>> "Yep."
>> And so, you got to be careful. They're
going to be singing. You're going to be
having this emotional response and it's
game over.
>> Yeah. You could take a Hill Song song
and replace the word Jesus with Lucifer
and you're going to feel those same
goosebumps. You're going to feel, "Oh
man, this is amazing." Right. Because
it's the power of the music, the
emotional of the music. It's not
>> not the words.
So, uh, let's go to some of these slides
here because this is some stuff I I'm
not sure that everybody knows this, but,
um, Charlie Kirk's wife is a Catholic.
>> Yeah, I didn't know about this.
>> Yeah, she's a baptized Catholic. So,
>> that's that's a that's a shock to me
because I was sharing with you and I
don't know how your what your audience
knows about Charlie, but Charlie has he
went up against this this other uh
>> Michael Nolles, right?
>> Michael Nolles. Yes. Thank you. Michael
Nolles and they were going back and
forth between Protestantism and
Catholicism and it was just going back
and forth and and I would say Charlie
had a lot of good points. He had a lot
of good points. So I'm thinking to
myself, man, here's this guy who's
Protestant and he's talking about the
the papacy or or sorry, he's talking
about Pope Francis as a Marxist
>> and these are like bold claims. You
don't just make these claims. Yeah.
>> You don't just say these things unless
you're going to be attacked, right?
Because that's a a a very important
system that they have established. And
so when you showed this to me, I thought
to myself, what on earth? I mean, how
can you even be divided like that?
That's a big divide.
>> Yeah.
>> The Protestantism and Cathol and
Catholicism. I would argue that might be
one of the greatest divides we have in
the entire world more than black and
white and all this other stuff they're
trying to do.
>> Protestantism and Catholicism. Where do
you where do you combine that? M
>> opposite thoughts.
>> So when I was sharing that I think that
this is all strategically planned out
for a purpose. Satan is trying to get
the left and the right to come get like
first there's going to be chaos order
out of chaos. So we have to come to like
a civil war or something. I believe that
there's just going to be chaos
everywhere and then ultimately Satan but
under the guise of, you know, the Pope
or whoever
>> will say, "Look, we need to bring we
need to we need to put in some strict
laws and and um because we need peace."
Um
so I was already looking at like this,
but I had people telling me like the no,
you're not seeing it right, you're
missing it. The Catholic Church hates
him. And I'm like that's not what I'm
seeing. I'm seeing like people taking
mass for Charlie. I'm seeing articles
about that, news articles, uh, priests
and stuff.
>> It's ecumenical. It is a It is a I mean,
that's that's essentially what it
became. Maybe he wouldn't have said it
himself, but what it became was this
ecumenical interfaith
kind of push to one direction.
>> Oh.
>> And we know where that direction's
going.
>> Yeah. I mean, this this right here says
that he w she was uh baptized baptized
Catholic. I actually heard a interview
where he says he says, "And my wife's
Catholic." So, this isn't something
like, "Well, just because she was
baptized Catholic as a baby doesn't mean
she's still Catholic." Oh, she is. I
mean, his her husband said it.
>> Believed it.
>> Um, here we see
>> that's the rosary.
>> Somebody posting it says, "Heartbreak in
Phoenix. Charlie Kirk's widow escorts
his body home. It says Erica Friend
friends, that's her maiden name. I don't
know how to say it, but held a rosary as
she waves. So, she's clearly devout
Catholic.
>> I think it's interesting the way she's
holding that. Was that you that
mentioned that?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. You spotted how she's holding that
between
>> You will see. Yeah. the finger and the
thumb repping the So, look, I'm not
gonna
>> There's so much u Go ahead.
>> I'm just I'm just saying I'm not gonna
make a whole case out of one hand sign,
but when you see it over and over, the
symbolism everywhere.
>> I mean, it's the same thing with these
movies and stuff, too. I'm not going to
build a whole case on like um oh, Darth
Vader, his name is Lord Vader, and so
he's like Jesus. No, he was actually he
wears the chest piece like the ephod the
high priest. He was a born without a
father. You know his name is they call
him Lord. So he's the prophesied chosen
one. So if he's the prophesied chosen
one who was born without a father wears
the ephod. His arm is in perfect white
perfect order and they call him Lord
Vader which is father. Then that's a
case you can make. I'm not going to
build I'm not going to make I'm not
going to believe something off of one
piece of the puzzle. There's got to be a
lot and there's there's going to be a
lot shown here.
Um this I just saw this today while
putting this together. Man, um do you
recognize what that is on her neck?
>> Are those uh are those Oh, you're
talking about the one in the top middle.
Yeah,
>> it's uh
some kind of a cult uh
symbolism.
>> Yeah, that's the Mounty's cross with a
crown on top of it.
>> And and I I looked it up. Mounty's cross
with a crown on it. And here this was a
website that actually on the on the left
I covered it up with her picture there,
but on the left there was like all these
links to to different like Masonic
jewelry. And it says yellow gold
maltizes cross royal crown pennant
necklace. So, okay, first she's she's
Catholic.
>> She's repping the the triple six hand
sign while holding a rosary. She's
wearing a Maltese cross which the
definition of the Maltese cross when
combined with a royal crown and a
pendant is a powerful and explicitly
Christian symbol is what AI is saying of
the York right of Freemasonry.
If you are awake at all you'll know that
Freemasonry is not Christian and it says
particularly for the Knights Templar
this emblem represents the triumph of
Christian virtue and the promise of
eternal life for the faithful. And it
says the combined symbol is a motto in
Hawk Signno Vinces Vinces's by this sign
you shall conquer. Do you know what that
is?
>> Think about
>> Yes.
That that takes us back to the uh um by
this sign you shall conquer. That take
us right back to Constantine.
>> Boom. You got it, bro.
>> Yes. So she's rocking a symbol that has
to do with Constantine
>> and says this phrase you this by this
sign you shall conquer which is a
translation of the Latin and it's the
Roman Emperor Constantine. So, she's
Catholic and she's wearing this Roman
Freemason throwing up the triple sixes,
holding the uh holding the rosary.
And I asked, did Roman Emperor
Constantine enforce a day of worship?
Because that's what's on my radar. I'm
looking for how is this how is
>> politics and religion going to unite?
How are we gonna have a mark of the
beast system where you must worship this
way or die and it's going to look like
peace and safety? Like how are we gonna
get to that? And so I'm thinking is she
like signaling is she wearing this
boldly on a necklace? And it says uh did
Roman uh R and did Roman Emperor
Constantine force a day of worship? Yes.
In 321 AD, Roman Emperor Constantine
issued a law making Sunday a day of
public rest, which wasn't solely for
Christian worship, but also honored the
existing pagan tradition, the day of the
sun. So, there was a time when worship
was enforced and it merged paganism and
Christianity. Even though Christians
weren't keeping Sunday,
he stopped killing Christians if they
would keep Sunday to to uh meet in the
middle with the pagans.
And so this is what you're talking
about. The Kirk, the Charlie Kirk effect
is mass mass attendance.
>> Catholic news agency mass attendance up
at various colleges in wake of Charlie
Kirk's assassination. So
>> right,
>> people are telling me, "Oh, the Catholic
Church hates him."
>> Right.
>> Uh
>> well, I mean, you would think that based
off some of the things he says, but I
mean, the ultimate
outcome is that it's interfaith. It's a
it's a one world religion push. It's
what they're using it for.
>> Yeah, dude. If you're married to a
Catholic,
how can you
>> I'm telling you, I don't know. I didn't
understand that when you told when you
showed that to me. I said, "That's
impossible.
How can you be a Protestant be married
to a devout
>> a a Sabbathkeeping pro a Sabbathkeeping
>> protest?" And and then you were saying
or or uh was it Candace or or someone
that was saying that, you know, how can
you be so stupid to continue to believe
this way? Just just come and just make
the switch already. Make the switch.
She's a very strong uh you know,
Catholic
uh proponent.
>> And she had Ali Beth Stucky on her um
show with her husband, another very
devout Catholic, and she was given a
case for Protestantism. And I was like,
man, look at her go. She did a great
job, too.
>> And and Charlie was the only other one
that did that. And now hearing about all
this other stuff, it's very it doesn't
make sense.
>> Yeah.
Uh so this made me think because right
now in this timing, 2025, they're
talking about the golden age and all
this stuff. Trump's been saying it like
first of all people that have been
watching our channel know that we talk
about this all the time but for first-
timers Alice Bailey and a cultist or
Helen Botsky both of them basically
we're saying that in the year 2025 is
going to be the externalization of the
hierarchy talking about demons
manifesting in our world. We just so
happen to see UFOs all over the place on
mainstream media news and the military
saying, "Yeah, they're real. They're
non-human intelligences. We don't know
they are." and
Trump saying that we're entering in the
golden age, which just happens to be the
age of Aquarius, which is exactly what
those ladies were talking about. The tw
that 2025 was going to be the age of
Aquarius when you're going to have this
externalization of the hierarchy,
meaning
>> Satan is going to manifest.
>> And brother, listen,
this is a turning point for the USA.
Okay?
>> Yeah.
>> This is a turning point for the USA.
And what?
>> Predictive programming.
>> Oh, Turning Point. I got you. Yeah,
>> that's that's his that's his that's his
organization. His organization is
Turning Point USA. Turning point.
>> This is a turning point.
>> Do you know where Turning Point is based
out of?
>> Everybody is
>> uh
No,
>> Phoenix, Arizona.
And
just just keep that in mind. Phoenix.
Okay. But she's she's rocking that
Maltese cross that has to do with
Constantine
and and we're talking about Charlie Kirk
and and Trump are like buds. And listen
to this.
Through your leadership, you embody the
values of our Christian faith and love
for the gospel.
You remind me of the great Roman Emperor
Constantine the Great.
[Applause]
That's a
>> Can you believe that response?
>> I mean, why does everyone just know
about that? I mean, that's just been
Constantine the Great, they all
>> dude that forced worship and he was
killing Christians.
>> Yeah, exactly. Why? Why? Why is it that
everyone seems to know all about their
history for Constantine and what he did
and why that's so great?
>> All right.
>> Makes you wonder, doesn't it?
>> Yeah.
Uh let's see. So, I think this is where
I should show this video. Let me make
sure. Actually, let me see.
>> I mean, we can go on and on.
>> Look at this.
New York, the sun.
>> Ah, yes, that one. to celebrate the
legacy of Carly Charlie Kirk. Not not to
celebrate your relationship with God. To
celebrate the legacy of Charlie Kirk who
put a premium faith who put a premium on
faith. Honor the Sabbath.
So
>> honor what Sabbath? What is the Sabbath?
>> Right? It depends on who you ask.
>> But the thing I mean I think it's
interesting that it says sun right
there. You know the New York sun. But
it's talking about the You got to see
those things.
>> Yeah. To celebrate the legacy of Charlie
Kirk, not not anything to do with
>> the God.
>> The sun.
The sun honor the Sabbath. That's that
to me is subliminal messaging. That's
that's my personal opinion. I I've been
seeing this kind of stuff all over the
place
>> for sure.
All right. So,
you you understand this stuff. We
understand this stuff. I hope I hope
people on the chat and stuff know about
this. But Revelation 13:15-16
is talking about and he had power to
give. Let me full screen this. He is
talking about when it says and he had
power, it's talking about the second
beast which we understand to be America.
The first beast is Rome and the second
beast is America. That's a huge study in
itself. But when you really look into
it, the first beast rose out of the
waters and there's everything points to
its Rome. I mean, the purple and
scarlet, the seven heads or seven
mountains, all of it. But as that beast
is falling, there's another beast ro uh
rising in the earth, not in the sea.
That represents many peoples. So what
superpower nation was rising in the
1700s when Rome was suffering a fatal
head wound? There's only one nation.
>> And it says that he had power to give
life unto the image of the beast. That
the image of the beast should both speak
and cause that as many as would not
worship the image of the beast should be
killed. Now people look at this stuff,
man. I've heard for years. I I believed
it even some of this stuff. I I used to
have a totally different understanding
of prophecy. I thought the microchip was
a the mark of the beast and I the image
of the beast could be AI or whatever.
And that's what people are thinking.
They're thinking the image of the beast
is like transhumanism or or AI, but a
beast is a kingdom.
>> That's what the Bible says. It says the
fourth beast is the fourth kingdom. Like
a beast is a kingdom. So if the first
beast is Rome and this second beast
which is America is making an image to
the first beast that just means that
it's it's trying to become just like the
first beast. America is becoming Rome.
>> And when you see these pictures up here
on the left is the Vatican and on the
right is Washington DC. Even in
>> structure
>> the very same structures.
>> Yeah. the same structures,
>> but now
>> has power to give. It has authority and
so you got to be very careful because
we're seeing it now happening now.
>> Yeah. And now it's going to speak like a
dragon. So
>> America is going to start making laws
that are like Rome. And what did Rome
do? Enforce worship. I mean, if you
don't kiss the Pope's ring, you burn at
the state, right?
>> Well, completely. I mean, one of the
biggest problems that the Vatican that
that Rome had was the the uh combination
of church and state. I mean, that's
that's what they were known for, right?
That's what was their problem. That was
what the problem was.
>> And so, we're the the image of that as
the United States is that we are going
to become church and state combined. and
all the stuff that we're seeing right
now, especially with the conservative
class, you are seeing
>> that combination that's like gonna be
pushing it forward. So,
>> well, they call it Christian
nationalist.
>> I mean, that so project 2025, Christian
nationalism, all that stuff is saying,
oh, the seven mountain mandate, man. If
you guys have not seen the stuff that
we've been talking about, like go
through our videos, man. We we've done
some videos about the seven mountain
mandate where the new apostolic
reformation they want to control as
Christians. They want to control
education, entertainment, government,
everything. And they think that's a good
thing. And Christians are all on board
because they're like, "Yeah, like
>> because it protects us from the LGBT
spirit and all this other
>> uh these social justice situations and
and all this stuff coming from the from
the from the grave." And it's like,
"Yeah, go ahead. Protect us from that
stuff. Protect our families from that.
Give us whatever whatever other
alternative there is."
>> That's right. And
>> we're losing our freedoms. Remember 911?
losing our freedoms
>> because we're afraid of Yeah. For
safety. Exactly.
>> Yep. That's what it's all about. Create
chaos so that you will freely give up
your
your rights and everything so that Yeah.
So you can feel safe. I mean, that's why
all this alien stuff and everything.
It's like, oh, we need a space force. We
need to build weapons pointed towards
the heavens so that we can fight Christ
when he returns. You wonder. I mean, a
real thinking person is is thinking that
sounds so stupid. Why would we do that?
>> Try to fight.
>> Well, try try to look out into the world
for aliens and things like that. But
they're pushing this. They're they're
pushing it and we're going to believe
it.
>> And it says that he's going to cause all
both small and great, rich and poor,
free and bond, to receive a mark in
their right hands or in their foreheads.
That's why people think it's a microchip
because you can't buy or sell without
it. Look, the fact that you can't buy or
sell is a punishment. It's not It's not
that the currency is the mark. It's
saying if you don't worship this way,
we're going to we're going to cut off
your ability to buy and sell. We're also
going to throw you in prison 10 days and
we're going to cut your head off. Those
things aren't the mark of the beast.
Those are the punishments for not
worshiping according to the one world
religion. Because if you don't believe
in coexistence, then you're a hater and
you're causing discord in our perfect
dystopian world. So you're going to get
locked up or or worse.
>> Not just believe, but affirm.
>> Yeah. And so the right hand is the
actions and the forehead is the belief.
So there's going to be some people that
they totally believe like this is it.
Like this is the truth. This is love and
tolerance and acceptance and I believe
in it. And then there's going to be
people that say, "You know what? I don't
believe in this system, but I'm not
going to risk my family's life or
anything, so I'm just going to go along
with it." And that's taking it in the
hand. You're doing it by works, not by
belief. But both ways are wrong. The
only way you can not get the mark of the
beast is to be sealed
with the seal of the living God in your
forehead. And that's not literal. It's
not a literal seal on your head. It's
obedience to God. It's believing and
obeying. It's it's both. Mhm. So, I'm
going to show this clip on the uh
>> Yeah,
>> this clip was pretty interesting from
Charlie Kirk here.
>> But let me first say I think we as
Protestants and Ev evangelicals under
venerate Mary. She was very important.
She was a vessel for our Lord and
Savior.
>> I think that we as evangelicals and
Protestants, we've overcorrected.
We don't talk about Mary enough. We
don't venerate her enough. Mary was
clearly important to early Christians.
There's something there. In fact, I
believe one of the ways that we fix
toxic feminism in America is Mary is the
solution. Have more young ladies be
pious, be
reverent, to be full of faith, slow to
anger, slow to words at times. Mary is a
phenomenal example and I think a counter
to so much of the toxicity of feminism
in the modern era.
>> Now he just said venerate Mary.
>> Was that the word you said she did? He
said
>> venerate. Yes, venerate.
>> You said that multiple times. It's not a
good word to use.
>> It's not a good word. Not not nowadays.
It's it's the word is almost solely
being used uh with this idea of you know
the Catholic
u
worship
>> and it's not it's not a good word to
use. I want to be honest in in the
research here because I was actually
putting together a video about how this
shooter was 200 yards away and yet when
you watch the video,
the sound of the gun happens the moment
he gets hit. And I was like, "Wait a
minute." No. Sound travels slower than
light or than than things that are, you
know, you can watch somebody dribbling a
basketball from a far away and you'll
see the ball hit and then you'll hear it
later. And I'm watching all these videos
and I'm putting a stopwatch on. I'm I'm
looking up videos of dudes shooting
targets from 200 yards away and it's
like pow
ding. I mean, it was like a minute or a
second and a half before you actually
heard the thing. And I was like, whoa,
whoa. This is like this don't line up.
and I was putting it together and I was
going to I was going to expose this
thing. But then I watched a video where
the camera was actually on the target
instead of next to the shooter and you
heard the sound right when it hit the
target because
the bullet is traveling and the sound is
traveling and they're making it about
the same time. And so I had to scrap the
whole thing. I really thought I was
like, "Dude, I'm going to tear this
thing up." Now, with this Mary thing, I
saw the whole clip
and right before he starts saying that,
he's actually saying, "I have a few
problems with Catholicism." And that's
when he says, he says, "My wife is a
Catholic, but I have a few problems with
Catholicism." And the main problem is
Marianism, or whatever, however you want
to say it. So he's saying he does a
problem he has with Catholicism is that
they venerate Mary. But then he's
literally saying we should venerate her.
So it is kind of strange.
>> Well well Mary is the is the answer. He
goes way too far when he says that Jesus
is the answer.
>> Amen to that.
>> Jesus is%
>> Jesus is the answer. Not Mary. Although
I do agree that, you know, uh, we can
use the Bible characters. If they have a
honorable character to emulate, that's
fine. We're not against that. All the
Bible characters have have the same uh
ability. You should be able to do that
for any of them.
>> Yeah. I don't really
>> Let's not go Let's not go that far.
Yeah.
>> I don't really know that there's much
talk about Mary in the Bible, though. I
don't know her character.
>> Not really. Uh she yeah she was chosen
by the Lord cuz she was uh you know
upright and humble and some of the words
that he used are true.
>> Um but let's not jump to Mary is the
answer.
>> Yeah. But this clip
this one this she just uploaded this.
This was today. No two days ago. Okay.
On the 15th. Well, it just changed to
the 17th. So basically a day ago she
posted this and this is what she says
about her friend Charlie Kirk.
>> Charlie
um
was definitely on the brink of changing
some of his perspectives and um I can
tell you factually Charlie was praying
the rosary. Charlie was going to mass.
>> One of my last conversations with
Charlie was me joking with him saying
just make the last step. Okay. you are
uh I said specifically, you're too smart
to be a Protestant. Just take the last
step, Charlie. He says, haha. You're
speaking about uh Mary. And typically
when those steps start taking place, you
stop referring to yourself as I did as a
Judeo-Christian.
>> She just said that he was talking about
Mary. like you're going to mass, you're
you're doing you're praying the rosary.
You're talking about Mary.
>> She's like, "Bro, you're a Catholic.
Like, just go ahead and make the
change."
>> It's like, "You might as well just make
the last step." Yeah. Jump jump jump
ship.
>> And uh I was I shared that in a a chat
that I'm in, a group that I'm in, and
people are saying, "Look, man, if if I
died, people could say anything about
me." But I'm like, "She's a personal
friend of his. She's talking about a
conversation they really had. She's got
millions of subscribers
>> level.
>> I don't think she's just going to come
out here and tell a boldfaced lie. Be
like, I remember this situation that
never happened, but I'm going to pretend
it did. I don't think that's I think
this is a reality.
So, that's interesting. So, who is
Charlie Kirk? I don't even know, man. I
don't know who he is, but I know that
there were some interesting things. And
I'm I'm going to go ahead and
say when any kind of these events
happen, whether it's a school shooting,
whether it's 9/11, you know, this is
what I believe.
And I believe that these people who do
this stuff
leave tags. You know, as a Christian, if
I'm a Christian performer or YouTuber or
I I'm going to thank God. I'm going to
say, "Lord, give me the right words to
say." Like, I'm going to incorporate
Christian things into the the content I
make or graphics I make or whatever.
They do it, too. Like, whether knowingly
or unknowingly, when Satan blesses them,
they're going to give props to their
master. One, either they're doing it
because they really are thankful, like
they're like, "My God blessed me. I'm
rich. I'm famous or they have to do it
to continue to get those quote unquote
blessings.
Like Satan's like, I'm not going to give
you these things unless you give me a
sacrifice or unless you flash this hand
sign everywhere. Unless you push my
agenda, you're not going to be blessed
anymore.
So, I also believe that Satan is a is a
counterfeit of everything God. And so,
God g what does it say? says he never
does anything without telling his
prophets first. Right.
>> Mhm.
>> And so Satan's like, "Okay,
I'm not going to do anything unless I
tell my prophets and they're going to
tell the world." And I I heard a quote,
it's actually by uh Albert Pike,
something similar to this, paraphrasing,
but he said, "I got it."
>> You have it something about symbols.
>> Yeah, I got it. Yeah. Oh. Um, Albert
Pike.
Let me see if I can pull it up. Um,
I don't have the one on the symbols. I
have the one Whenever the people need a
hero, we shall supply him.
>> That's
>> That one's a scary one, too, if you
think of it.
>> That's a deep That's a deep one because
it actually goes along with what we're
talking about. But I thought you were
referring to that one. No, there's
another one where he says uh symbols are
to hide hide the truth from those who
don't understand and to
>> something like that.
>> Give the truth to those who have eyes to
see. So, if you're a Mason and you're
and everybody's watching a movie and
there's some weird hand sign, nobody's
going to know what that is. They're
going to be like, "Oh, it's Spider-Man.
That's how he does his like his web or
whatever." And the Mason's like, "Oh, I
know that hand sign." Or whatever. you
know, or a um a musician flashes a sign
in a photo shoot or whatever, right? So,
>> I'm always like tipping your hat.
>> Yes. Exactly. So, I'm always looking for
things
>> us.
>> Exactly.
Because they're putting in our faces.
So, when I heard that the the shooter
was caught 33 hours later, come on. Not
not 30 hours, not 34 hours, but 33 hours
later. That's how long the manhunt took.
Um,
people are losing their jobs. We can
talk about this, too. People are losing
their jobs.
>> For being insensitive about what
happened. When has that ever happened?
Like
>> that sounds like uh their it sounds like
the uh the
the same exact verbiage, the same
language that we hear from the other
extreme and now it's coming on this
side. We're hearing cancel culture,
>> right?
>> Is um it's coming on our side now.
>> Like you better say the right pronoun or
you're going to be in trouble.
>> Exactly. Exactly. To me that is
hypocritical.
>> Yeah. And I'm just trying to look at it
uh from a fair and unbiased perspective.
When you look at that and they say, "All
right, now everyone's going to lose
their jobs." I'm not saying, no one is
saying that we need to be talking
negatively. I mean, that is terrible to
do.
>> Yeah.
>> If someone dies, don't, you know, don't
talk negatively about that. Yeah. You
can
>> a mom and pop shop say, "Hey, I don't
like that. That's that's not right."
Right. But I mean, you start looking at
it where it's becoming this nationwide
or worldwide thing where people are
losing their jobs. People are women are
coming out and saying, "Did you see that
video where she was like, I'm afraid,
telling her friends, you know, be
careful if you say something,
>> they're they're coming against us now.
We can't we don't have freedom of
speech.
>> We don't have the freedoms that we had
before
>> this took place."
>> Oh, that's so freedom of speech,
>> freedom of speech is literally dying
except hypocritically because now on the
conservative side, it was always the
liberals, right?
always little.
>> Yeah.
>> But you know, CNN,
all that kind of stuff, those those
those channels, but now you're having
the same exact language and the same
exact stuff happening on the right. It's
not right.
>> That's crazy.
>> It's hypocritical.
You just reminded me of uh
well, I can't find it, but
the the liberals, they I remember they
were walking out holding a white banner
that said free speech and they're
setting on fire. They're the ones that
have hate speech.
>> Like, you're not allowed to say certain
things if it's hateful. But it doesn't
work for white heterosexual Christian
male.
>> No, no, no.
>> You can talk about you can bash my God.
You can make fun of my beliefs, uh, mock
me all day long, and I can't say
anything because I'm privileged. That's
my privilege is that I don't have any
protection. But if I call a male a male,
I can I can be penalized somehow.
So here, I just thought it was
interesting. 33 people lost their jobs.
So 33 hours to catch the assassin. 33
people lost their jobs. Like I said, I'm
not going to make a case out of one
thing, but when you see a pattern, why
do people not notice patterns and think
that that's not normal? Um, this might
be a stretch for some people, but these
people are obsessed with numerology.
Nothing is by accident.
>> Somebody laid those hats out just like
this.
>> Each hat says 47. 4 + 7 is 11. There
just happens to be three of them. And if
you add 11 three times, you get 33.
Um,
Miss Erica Kirk came out and gave a
speech and for the first 10 15 minutes
>> Yeah. For the first 10, 15 minutes, it
it just had this picture on the screen.
It just had begin soon. And then some
guy comes out and he's testing the audio
and stuff and then she finally comes out
and it just happens that it ends at 33
minutes. I mean, come on. Is all of this
a coincidence?
Um,
I'm going to play this video clip. It
It's It might be like 3 minutes long,
but I want you to see that this is a
pattern that happens all the time. And
if you just ignore it, then you're
really just being willfully ignorant.
So, check this out.
And I say as of today, at this hour, uh,
we have 33 confirmed positive tests of
the virus. Yesterday we had 22 cases.
Today we have 33 cases. So it has gone
up by 11.
Uh that brings those are 11 new cases.
Uh 22 goes to 33.
>> As we sort through this here uh in
Arkansas. Uh today uh we have 33
confirmed positive cases in Arkansas.
>> Uh as of today we have 33 confirmed
cases uh with Boston residents. We
expect those numbers to climb.
>> As of this afternoon, we have 33
Pennians who have tested positive for
COVID 19.
>> Um, so as of this morning, there were 33
confirmed cases in North Carolina.
>> Evening to you. Lots to get to tonight.
I'm Leon Hendricks. We want to start
with new information into our newsroom.
Within the past couple of hours, there
are now 33 confirmed cases of the Corona
virus in Michigan. Good evening
everyone. Thanks for joining us for the
news at 6. I'm Richard Gearhard. Karina
Carral has the night off. More cases of
the Corona virus were confirmed today in
San Los Aispo County, bringing the total
number now to 33.
>> Right now, Georgia is reporting a total
of 99 cases in 19 counties. That is 33
new cases from just yesterday.
>> Good afternoon. I'm Karen Swenson. More
cases and more events affected. Here is
the latest Corona virus news. There are
now 33 cases in Louisiana.
>> As expected,
>> as expected,
>> the number of cases of CO 19 jumps. A
total of 33 people in our state have
been tested and are confirmed to have
the Corona virus.
>> Day four of the shelter at home order
brought six new confirmed cases of the
Corona virus to St. Louis Abyispo
County, bringing the total number to 33.
>> All troopers will be professional,
polite, and will treat everyone with
dignity and respect. these latest steps
as the number of confirmed COVID 19
cases in Rhode Island jumps by 33
overnight.
>> And with four more deaths reported
overnight, the death toll now stands at
at least 33. 33 33.
>> The Ministry of Public Health has
confirmed a batch of 33 new COVID 19
patients. Thailand now has an
accumulated number of cases.
[Music]
The Ministry of Public Health has
reported that the number of confirmed
cases of COVID 19 in Thailand remains at
33. 10 new confirmed cases have been
reported in Malaysia, bringing the total
now to 93. Health Director General D.
Dr. Lord Hisham Abdullah said they were
first and second generation close
contacts of case 33.
>> 33. It's all just coincidence though.
>> No, there's no way that that could be a
coincidence. Listen, I mean, come on.
Every state
>> it's it's all 33 now.
>> Other countries.
>> Come on. I mean, yeah. And then that
>> I heard in those same clips, I heard 11
11 6 22 33. It's like always those
numbers. Even in this Even in this
event, how old was the assassin? 22.
I mean, it it's just it goes on and on,
man.
[Music]
>> Um h I don't know if we should jump that
one yet. Let me see.
>> I was trying to find that thing there.
The the assassination. We we haven't
really talked a lot about that. Um the
the do you know his name? The boy, the
man.
Do you know much? Do do we have much
about that? The transgender
and who actually did it because it does
not look
when you look at it, it just does not uh
nothing adds up actually.
>> And it's difficult to believe that uh
you know they plant these guys.
>> I haven't looked at it yet. I I have his
name up here somewhere. Tyler something
I think. So,
are you seeing the screen?
Yeah. So, this is where things are are
headed though now, right? There's like
it was the the left was real crazy.
>> Yeah. Yeah. This is important.
>> Well, what did you see about this?
Because you actually found this article.
>> Uh, well, the whole point of this is
that they're dividing the nation. I mean
that's the whole point is that they are
Trump is using this he's basically
exploiting this man's death.
>> Yeah. he's exploiting or or you know
fill in the blank whatever you believe
>> right
>> but the point is that
>> on the outside he is exploiting this
man's death
>> and uh the whole goal is to make
Democrats look evil make the liberal
class look bad make all those that are
connected with them the DEI the LGBT and
all this kind of stuff um um come out to
seem more and more and more and more
evil
So that it pushes against the uh the
conservative class. So so that that the
conservative class says this is this is
this is too much. Something's got to
give. We do you have any of those
articles where they're talking about how
we need to strap up and we need to fight
back and we need to you know this is a
civil war essentially is what we're
looking at right now. And thanks that
one's important too. I really think that
you should play that because it gives
really really clear perspective to how
the liberal side is seeing it.
>> Yeah.
>> And how afraid they are of freedom of
speech is under attack. They see the
hypocrisy. They're afraid
>> uh all that kind of stuff. You need to
show that so we can see that this is a a
right and a left Hegelian dialectic.
>> Yep.
>> Divide and conquer tactic.
>> Boom. Whatever you're doing right now,
stop and watch this video. The right has
begun a doxing campaign for anybody they
believe does not have enough sympathy in
the wake of Charlie Kirk's death.
Despite championing free speech and the
ability to say whatever you want,
including slurs and hate speech, they've
begun to dox people who say, "I don't
necessarily care that he has died." This
is the website and they've begun to
write people's names, addresses if they
can find it, and their employer's names
as well as specifically what they have
said. If you are somebody who posts
online right now, I would encourage you
to be very careful because throughout
American history, we've seen that people
on the left are routinely the people who
are punished rather than those on the
right. And even now, our free speech is
under attack about what we can or cannot
say at universities or schools. Make
sure you aren't on there. And if you see
somebody you know, inform them. If you
feel like you're in danger, you can get
on an anti-SWAT registry. And also take
additional precautions while walking
around outside. The thing that they want
here is vengeance. So, they're really
going after people's jobs. So, be very,
very careful. And if you do speak
online, honestly, try not to show your
face or any identifying information. And
please be careful because this is
absolutely not right.
>> Okay. So,
>> there is something I want to say to
that.
>> She is um but listen how she said that
it is the
>> the the left that has been historically
>> um you know uh persecuted or whatnot.
But what she doesn't understand and what
she's actually wrong about is that she's
only looking at it from one side. She's
actually on that side looking out and
saying, "Look how crazy these people
are." You're going to see in this next
clip this that guy does the same thing.
He's going to say, "You guys are nuts.
You guys are nuts. You guys are insane."
Hypocritically speaking,
>> yeah,
>> this guy right here,
>> I'm going to lose my mind if
conservatives keep pretending like
mocking Charlie Kart's death makes you
some disgusting, horrible human being.
Especially when they reacted to the
death of nearly every black person in
the last 15 years like this. Like when
Trayvon Martin died, they held meet and
greets with George Zimmerman and asked
him to sign bags of Skittles and cans of
iced tea. And the gun that he used to
kill Trayvon Martin was auctioned off
for like quart of a million dollars.
Like the hypocrisy is insane. Every
single time a black person has been the
victim of police brutality, you guys
have dug up their entire history to try
to prove that they somehow deserved it.
But when we use Charlie Kirk's own
words, you say that we're heartless and
disgusting people for it. And even
though I know that the entire
conservative platform is just built on
hypocrisy, the amount of gaslighting
that I'm seeing is actually crazy. Like
people saying, "Well, we never
celebrated anyone's death. We never
mocked anyone's death. We felt bad that
those things happened." Like, we saw
your reaction in real time. Your digital
footprint is out there. Like the same
people who were just mocking alligator
Alcatraz, saying that immigrants were
going to be the perfect meal, and taking
their families there for photo shoots
are trying to claim they have a moral
high ground because we won't mourn the
person who enabled that culture in the
first place. You guys are delusional.
You've genuinely lost it.
>> Absolutely 100%.
>> There is something that I want to say
say on that because this guy is bitter.
He's angry and he is also missing the
point because he is coming at it in the
same angle from the left and he is mad
and he wants justice and he's he's going
to fight for it and he's going to push
against the right.
>> Anytime you have the left pushing
against the right, anytime you have the
right pushing against the left, you've
already lost. There's no way that you
can win with that kind of civil war.
It's the civil war mentality spirit that
they are pushing on both sides and he
sees it clearly and then they see it
clearly and they're both being pointed
to each other as the problem. Trump is
doing it with the Democrats. He's saying
it's all the Democrats. I've heard I
have a lot of, you know, friends that
are on that side and they say it's those
Democrats. Those Democrats are are evil
evil snakes.
>> Mhm.
>> But they're missing the point. They're
our brothers and sisters and yeah, they
believe in things that we don't agree
with. You know, they're less
conservative, abortion and whatnot,
other things like that. But another
thing that I wanted to mention was that
this guy um you know and and I don't
know if you have any information on the
the Ukrainian girl that was
>> uh if you put anything light on there
but they re these two situations with
Charlie Kirk and her death. They really
go hand in hand.
>> Yeah. Because both of those are
basically like one is in a large way
pushing against the LGBT and the
wickedness of this world with Charlie
and really DEI and all these kinds of
things, these social constructs, but
this this other girl that was attacked,
you see all these, you know, black
people around her and it's almost like,
and I really do believe that they are
pushing this racism on both sides. You
are pushing blacks to be afraid of
whites, whites to be afraid of blacks.
It's like there are brothers completely
are brothers and sisters, but they're
pushing this divide. They're pushing
LGBT versus Christians. They're pushing
black versus white, women versus men.
Anything that they can do to create a
divide. And that's what this is all
about. This whole entire thing with
Charlie is being exploited
>> to be a civil war. and pay attention
because of all the things that we've
mentioned, start looking at the
articles, start watching the the videos.
It's civil war. Don't be caught on
either side, right or left, or you're
going to be part of the problem. You're
going to get sucked in. You're going to
get emotional
>> like those guys,
>> the the the girl and the guy that we
just showed. Super emotional,
brokenhearted, and it breaks my heart.
>> Yeah.
>> Because they're sucked in. So anyway,
>> everybody wants to be a part of
something and that's why people join.
That's why when people have broken
families, they join gangs, they join the
Freemasons, whatever, get involved in
all kinds of stuff. We all want to be a
part of something. So when BLM happened,
people are like, "Yeah, you know, black
lives do matter." I'm going to stand
with that. But
>> I want to,
>> but if you try to say all lives matter,
you're a racist, you know. So, and and
we saw Oh, it's so crazy how
it it depends on who's president. Like
when we had a Democrat, it was all these
riots and everything happening and the
it was all about liberal stuff. Now we
got a Republican and it's an uprising is
going to happen for conservative values,
>> which really shouldn't even happen. We
shouldn't be
>> doing these kind of uprisings for this
reason. Um,
>> definitely outside of Christ's teachings
>> since he brought up some of these other
things. I thought this was interesting.
George Floyd, there was a lot of weird
stuff with that, too. Um, like I said, I
question everything. All these
events that happen, I look forward.
>> Anything that becomes mainstream,
>> anything that it's pushed, anything
that's pushed down your throat,
>> I don't believe it. That's my
conviction. I do not believe any of it.
I think it's I think it's a programming
ploy.
>> Right. You see his birthday October 14.
>> I don't know what the significance is,
but look, Charlie Kirk, October 14.
>> They were both
>> I did not see that
>> martyrs that are going to cause an
uprising, right?
>> What are the chances
>> when you start seeing
interesting
>> patterns? Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
How many years apart?
>> 93 73.
20 years apart.
Like to the day 20 years exactly.
>> Yeah. To the day. Exactly. 20 years
apart.
>> And both these men were
>> like that
>> murdered in a way that caused some kind
of uprising, right?
>> Some big Yeah. Yeah. But but pay
attention because both sides are the
polar opposite of each other.
>> Yeah.
>> Same birthday, 20 years apart. Exactly.
two of the exact uh uh what you want the
right and what you want the left to
have.
>> Yeah.
>> And it's it's if you can see through
this, then you'll be better off. But
>> yeah,
>> it's so clear. This I thought was crazy
because we understand me and you and a
lot of other people understand that
there is like two great errors that are
going to
really unite this one world religion and
it's Sunday sacredness and
spiritualism. spirit.
>> And so the Sunday sacredness, you know,
it was already it already happened when
Constantine enforced Sunday worship. And
if you were caught Judaizing, which
meant keeping God's fourth commandment,
you were persecuted. And we live in a
day where basically all denominations
keep the venerable day of the sun. No
matter what denomination you are, you're
still bowing to Rome because they were
the ones that openly admit we changed
the day and you guys keep it. So, if
that's news to anybody here, the fourth
commandment is is clear and we're we're
obeying man rather than God. And what
did Jesus say? He said, "You make the
commandments void by your tradition." He
said,
>> "Oh, this one's really powerful." He
>> "You worship me in vain." Because people
say, "Oh, it's all just about I I
believe Jesus. I believe, so I'm good to
go. You worship me in vain by keeping
the commandments of men." I'm like,
"Wow, you can actually worship Jesus in
vain." There's going to be many people
that say, "Lord, Lord, they're calling
him, Lord, didn't we do all these great
things in your name? Cast out devils and
miracles and all this stuff." He said,
"I never knew you. Depart from me, you
workers of lawlessness. You didn't
listen to me. You didn't obey me. Why
call me Lord and do not the things that
I tell you? How can you call him Lord
and Master and simply not obey his
perfect laws of liberty?
But this is a church in I think this is
in Arizona. Yeah, in Phoenix, Arizona.
And it says Dream City Church features
an AI Charlie Kirk and compares him to
Jesus preaching about spiritual war
after Kirk's death. The Phoenix church
used AI to recreate Kirk's voice at
Sunday service. I'm not gonna play it.
It was a long video anyway. It was a It
was a whole church sermon, but there was
a little piece in there and he's
explaining how he said, "I debated
whether to share this cuz, you know,
it's AI and all that stuff." Uh, I think
it's a lot more than just AI being the
issue here, but some girl, a little girl
asked AI, "What would Charlie Kirk say
to me if he were alive today?"
And they played it at church and people
are listening intently and applauding
real bad. And this is what he was
saying. He said, um, let me full screen
this. He was saying, "First, I want you
to know that I'm fine." Wait a minute.
Thought
>> I thought you were dead. I want you to
know I'm fine. Said said a disembodied
voice from the speakers inside Dream
City Church in Phoenix on Sunday. To me,
I'm I'm picking up all kinds of trigger
words.
>> Wow.
>> Phoenix City. Yeah. Dream.
>> Yeah.
>> So, um, and then it goes on and says,
>> "Dream point.
>> My soul is secure in Christ." The voice
said, "Death is not the end. It's a
promotion.
As the congregation of roughly 4,000 sat
silently enthralled,
all 4,000 people are practicing
divination.
>> Because look,
>> I I use AI. I'm not against the tool.
I'm against using a tool the wrong way.
Just like I'm against using TV the wrong
way or cell phone. Yeah. There's a right
way and a wrong way to use music,
movies, everything. I'm never going to
get on AI and say, "hm, what would this
person say?" You're openly inviting
Satan to deceive you. Yeah.
>> To pretend to be a
>> Yeah. familiar spirit.
>> You know, there's no power in a Ouija
board, but as soon as you pull it out,
you're giving a signal. I'm wanting to
communicate with the other side, which
are demons in disguise. And so you're
telling you're giving permission at that
point when you get on AI and you say
>> no
>> if you're a demon talk to me, you know,
or if you say, "Hey, I want to talk to
somebody dead." You're practicing
necromancy.
Did you have you seen this? This is on
>> No. What is this?
>> This is on Erica's Instagram. This is
her official Instagram. I didn't play
the whole thing. It's It's a short
video, but it's just saying something
about like what if what if childhood
lasted forever or something like that.
Anyway, nobody knows. I've looked
through the comments. Nobody knows what
this date is she's promoting. But look
when this was uploaded. September 2nd.
September 2nd. Now, watch what it says.
Okay. So, it's it's this weird thing.
It's just like music's playing and it's
saying like what if childhood lasted
forever blah blah blah and it's like
walk with us or something and then it
says I am which I think is interesting
because
>> you know Beyonce and Mariah Carey and
all these people they always do this
like I am Beyonce and all this stuff. It
says I am
>> yeah I am 916 and it's saying uh walk
the countdown with us 916 2025. Now,
this was posted September 2nd,
days before the supposed assassination.
What is she even promoting here? They're
all dressed in what?
They're all dressed in black.
>> Even the kids are wearing black
t-shirts.
Like, what are you promoting here? And
it just so happens that Tuesday,
September 16, 2025 is the date of the
first court appearance for the suspect
in Carly Ch Charlie Kirk's murder. Tyler
Robinson, 22, again, was arrested. So,
they're saying there there's a push for
him to be executed. Like, we want
capital punishment. Bring back the death
penalty. The death penalty is kind of
like on the fence right now. Like not a
lot of people do it, but right now this
has got so many people up in arms that
they're like, "Death penalty. I don't
care if you got to change the law.
>> We want the guillotines."
>> Wow.
>> You know, the the Bible says that
there's going to be a religion pushed by
law. And if you don't do it, it's
punishable by death. How are you going
to get to that point unless something
brings us there, right?
and and dude, she she posted that
September 2nd and it and I don't know
what it was supposed to be promoting
because that's today
and
>> Yeah, that's today.
>> Yeah. And I I don't know. I I looked and
saw what was his final verdict or
whatever. I couldn't see anything, but
>> probably aren't there yet,
>> but this is this is where we're at now.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Here we go. Here's more of
the separation.
>> Yeah. Do we fix this country? How do we
come back together?
>> I'll tell you something that's going to
get me in trouble, but I couldn't care
less.
>> The radicals on the right often times
are radical because they don't want to
see crime. The radicals on the left are
the problem, and they're vicious and
they're horrible. For years, those on
the radical left have compared wonderful
Americans like Charlie to Nazis and the
world's worst mass murderers and
criminals. This kind of rhetoric is
directly responsible for the terrorism
that we're seeing in our country today.
[Music]
>> I honestly can't believe they released
the AI video of Trump.
That was AI.
>> His fingers disappear and everything.
There's glitches. His fingers disappear
and everything.
>> Listen, the the the whole that's the
whole outcome. That's the whole point.
He wants us to hate. Look
>> Mhm. Radical left is is there's a lot of
bad there. Radical right, there's bad
there.
>> That's beside the point. We're not
getting distracted here on these points
>> is that they're trying to make a divide
and they're trying to get us to fight
each other. Civil war.
>> These are things that need to be deeply
understood. We don't we don't
Trump doesn't speak on my behalf. He
doesn't represent me. He's the
president. We respect him to the degree
that he is a president. But beyond that,
he is uh dangerous. I would agree with
the radical left actually in some
regard. And some of the things he says
are actually very dangerous.
>> Yeah.
>> And so
>> to act like violence is only bad when
this group of people do it, but when we
do it, it's for a different motive. So,
>> exactly. And listen to how he said
the radical right is only radical
because they don't
>> deal with the left.
>> That's the only problem with us. We're
perfect. Other than that, we're great.
And let me just talk to talk about Trump
for one more second.
>> And I want you to listen to this because
this is going to kind of
>> really, I think, add some context to
what's going on right now. But back in
2018,
not too long ago, Trump said, "It will
be hard to unify the country." Listen to
this. I would love to be able to bring
back our country into a great form of
unity. Trump said,
>> "But without a major event,
>> oh wow,
>> without a major event where people pull
together, brother, we are seeing it
now." Yep.
>> Listen to that. Listen to the language.
Without a major event that would pull
people together.
>> You mean like all the churches surging
now? And
>> that's hard to do. Yes. Oh,
>> but I would like to do it without that
major event
>> because usually that major event is not
a good thing. So he said that
uh it will be hard to unify the country
without a major event. That is the
scariest thing I could hear. And now
you're saying on the on the right
Charlie Kirk's death feels like where am
I? Where am I? uh the the far-right
commentators are now calling for
um war. Right-wing figures are calling
for retribution and they're calling for
a civil war. So, yeah, we are we have
that perfect way out, if you will, that
that opportunity to now unite the
country.
>> Never let the the Democrats are gonna
>> Yeah. Say that.
>> Yeah. I said, "Never let a good crisis
go to waste."
>> Exactly.
>> Yeah. What was up with this thing?
>> Yeah. So, this is the other side. This
is exactly the opposite. It's It's two
extremes. As the Trump administration
attacks trans people, some queer for
folks are armed and ready to bash back.
Are you triggered?
>> Quite literally, what's happening is it
is a furthering of the divide.
they are giving a message and I think a
lot of people are actually under legit
spells where when you hear stuff like
this are you triggered they're like boom
yeah I am triggered what
>> and they're like and but but listen to
the language because when you say are
you triggered you're usually saying are
you like offended like
>> right
>> so it's like yeah I am offended
triggered right so it's this double
language but what it's really doing is
that it's teaching people it's casting a
spell upon on people to become the exact
opposite of what is we are now seeing on
the right. So the left are becoming
triggered, the right are becoming
triggered and uh it's going to end in
crazy bloodshed and a crazy civil war.
And I think a lot of our liberal
brothers and sisters are are could very
well be uh destroyed.
>> Yeah.
>> Because of this. I want to see if I can
find this real quick. Uh
it what you're saying I I had wanted to
discuss this and I I'm glad you reminded
me because I almost forgot. But let's
see. This is it. Let me switch over.
Okay. So, Revelation 18:23.
And the light of a candle shall no more
at all shall shine no more at all in
thee. And the voice of the bridegroom
and of the bride shall be heard no more
at all in thee. For thy merchants were
the great men of the earth. That's our
time right now. For by thy sorceries
were all nations deceived. Now we often
talk about how this is the Greek
pharmarmacia. We get the word pharmacy
and all that stuff. It's true. every
anything that medicates the mind,
anything that puts you under a spell is
what's happening here. We're all nations
deceived. Uh this is that's that's a
good point to to notice. All nations
deceived because right now we're going
to show video of it. Every nation is
like I didn't even know they knew who
Charlie Kirk was, but all the nations
are like rallying in the streets by thy
sorceries. What is sorcery? Well, what
do they call it? Movie magic. Holly
wood, which is the wood of the witch's
wand that casts its spell broadcast it.
>> Yeah, dude. We're talking about magic
kingdom. All this stuff that comes from
the tell lie vision. People want to say
these things, but then they still fall
for the trap because of their emotions.
They say, "I don't believe anything
comes out of TV." And now with this
situation, they're like, "No, not him.
This is now you're like you crossed the
line
>> and now this is you cross the line. This
is
>> Yep.
>> Um yeah,
>> dude. This I couldn't believe it when
you showed me this, man. This is crazy.
Elon,
he's like Trump's right-hand man. I
mean, I heard they're like on outs or
whatever, but all of it's fake, man.
It's all a scripted soap opera. It's
like It's like wrestling.
>> Yeah. That's what he says to somebody in
the UK.
>> And you see how much violence there's on
the left uh with our our friend Charlie
Cook getting murdered in cold blood this
week and people on the left celebrating
it openly.
The left is the party of murder
and celebrating murder.
I mean, let let that sink in for a
minute.
[Music]
That's who we're dealing with here.
>> That is who we're dealing with. Violence
is coming to you.
>> You either fight back or you die.
>> And that's the truth.
>> When you have
>> Okay. Say what?
>> When you have big name people.
>> Yes. What he's doing is he's casting a
spell on the crowd. Yeah.
I mean, that's all it is.
>> Yeah, because there's probably there's
people that are probably there.
>> Fight back or you die.
>> Wait, I don't want to die,
>> right?
>> I better fight back against the
bloodstained left.
>> Yeah,
>> you have to understand the psychology
behind this stuff.
>> Yeah, there's probably people that were
there simply just because they're like,
you know what, I I want to hold up a
picture of Charlie and and remember him
or something. And then
>> the richest man on the world, the
richest man on earth
>> gets on a camera and says, "You guys
need a fight or you're gonna die." This
is like
>> like Hunger Games or something, right?
Like super villain.
>> You can't make this stuff up. What we
are seeing right now is a scripted play.
It is an act. Nothing is real.
>> Yep.
>> Sorry, but real
>> movie magic.
>> They're casting spells. It's the power
of suggestion.
>> Yeah.
>> To spell, to say, to enunciate.
>> Grimmoire, grammar. It's all it is is
speaking. Yeah.
>> And suggesting things, insane things
that will cause you to be afraid and
listen and obey,
>> man. So, here they are. Um,
>> all over the world. South Korea. There's
no sound on here. It was just music. For
some reason, the sound didn't come
through. But
>> England. And the reason why it's such a
big deal is because there are people in
secret societies all around the world
that are pushing this.
>> Exactly.
>> And I'm not again I'm not saying that we
we are not saying be insensitive.
We're not saying do not care about
death. That's sad stuff for sure 100%.
>> But this this is bigger because what we
are seeing is a divide.
And if we fall for this this split,
there's going to be a civil war that's
going to happen because of this
situation with this this this this
assassination or whatever you want to
call it. We're looking at a
at a civil war.
Yeah, you took the words right out of
the next slide's mouth right here.
Uh civil war mentions surge online after
Kirk assassination. Like that's New York
Times. Like they're saying the phrase
civil war on social media and stuff is
surging right now because of the death
of one person. Like
I just I can't think of any other person
that was there a civil war when Jesus
died. I mean come on Jesus was
definitely
>> he taught his disciples not to not to
fight.
>> Yeah. But I mean he changed the world.
He people are still
>> having their lives changed and
transformed by him. And yet there wasn't
a civil war breakout. This is like
you're saying this is a spell. This is
>> using the media, the propaganda to
incite violence to create the divide.
And like you said, it's on everything.
Race, gender,
>> politics, religion,
>> 100% all all these things. Um
>> um and and so why do people, you know,
this is what trips me out is before this
happened,
I heard a lot of soundminded people who
said, "Oh yeah, we're against the
Christian nationalist movement. We
should you should not combine church and
state together. It's it's going to lead
into the one world religion. It's going
to end up in persecution." All this
stuff. Like they understood it
completely. But the person who's like
the n the Christian nationalist icon
according to this article for some
reason we trusted him for some reason
he's he's involved in politics he's
involved in Christian nationalists he's
got the platform of the mainstream media
and for some reason we just let our
emotions take over like and didn't even
question if he's somehow an insider
somehow
being used as a tool or a puppet. What
What did we think? What how do we think
that Satan is going to win the Christian
conservatives? Unless there is somebody
That's how the Jesuits work, man. They
they infiltrate churches and you don't
even realize that the whole church
evolves in a matter of years
>> and they come out of nowhere, too.
>> Yeah.
So, speaking of Jesuits,
this, like I said, if it was one time,
one little hand sign or whatever, I'm
not going to ma mainly, you know, I hate
when people will take a screenshot of
somebody talking and gesturing and and
then it's like, oh, look at him. He did
that okay sign. He's a Illuminati. No,
when people talk that
>> Yeah. When people talk, they gesture.
But when you take a photo op and it's
like, "Oh, you're going to take a
picture here. Let me put my my finger
and my thumb together and extend my
three fingers. Hold on. Let me make this
diamond shape with my hand, this
compass.
It's not an accident."
>> Yeah. any and
>> pull up the uh pull up the hand signs
and you can show them that it's what
you're saying is absolutely 100%
repeatable all around the world.
>> Yeah.
>> And there's different there's different
ones. There's different ones. There's
the the the 666 the AOK sign. There's
the the one that he's doing in the
middle. I mean, you see all kinds of
politicians do that one. You see Trump
do it. You see, everyone seems to be
they all seem to do the same types of uh
signs. And after a while, you start
getting uncomfortable and wondering why
is it then that they all stand in front
of people or or places and do the same
symbols.
>> Yeah.
>> You see it in popes, you see it with
popes, you see with leaders, you see it
with uh pastors.
There's some of them.
There's that one.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I mean, the diamonds over the eye
and all this stuff
>> out there. This is real. Like, people
really do this. The occult is is they're
obsessed with this stuff.
>> Numerology,
uh, symbols, you know, pentagrams. Every
major corporate logo is a sun, an
eyeball, a pyramid, you know, some false
god like Starbucks chick. I mean they
are giving allegiance to
>> yeah the kaducus
>> like these people are giving allegiance
to who made them rich and famous.
Um
and then this this was a video that was
released. There are many strange things
about this. People are saying
this looks like a mannequin. They never
showed his face. I don't nobody's even
mentioning that his button is undone. I
don't know why that is. And who is
recording her with their camera all up
like literally right by her ear?
Recording her grieving over the death of
her husband. Who's doing that?
>> That's what that's why I'm saying that
the whole thing looks scripted. I mean,
it sounds scripted.
>> They are giving you footage. They're
constantly giving you footage. Do do you
remember I don't know if you were
younger and you would watch like the
sitcoms or whatever and they would come
on every week and you'd be like talking
with your friends and stuff like that.
It's like that. It's like that for news.
People are like, "Did you hear the
latest scoop, the latest this,
>> the latest that?" "Yeah, I heard he did
that and she did that." And it's like,
"What? I didn't even know that."
>> So, it's just a bunch of
it's it's difficult. It's difficult to
believe.
>> And and and this is the thing, too. It's
like we're building a case. It's not
just because the wife is a Catholic and
had a rosary. Like, she was wearing the
Maltese cross. She's wearing a ring that
has a letter on it that's not any other
letter but a G of all things.
You know, I'm just looking.
>> Stands for generative principle, right?
>> Well, the the grand architect. Yeah. The
Freemason. Yeah. Stands for many
different things. Grand Architect. Some
people say God and all this stuff,
but it it's
like we've been saying, we're not on
here trying to be insensitive or
anything, but we're seeing some strange
things, some strange patterns that have
been happening with all these events. We
can't turn a blind eye or else we're
just literally like burying our head in
the sand and waiting to be taken over.
I I don't
>> we're seeing we're seeing a very very
dangerous move for civil war and we want
to make sure that we can make others
understand that.
>> Yeah. Michael Jordan, you know, he chose
that number 23 because it's it's all
these numbers 32 23 things are inverted,
flipped around, upside down 66
>> flavors.
>> Yeah. 66 99 all that stuff. Why? She
just happened to be wearing that number,
showing that on her Instagram.
And you know, her her maiden name was
that Fron or whatever. And she went to
Regis University. She was on the
basketball team there.
And what do you what do you know about
Regis University? I didn't know anything
about it, but check it out. Regis
University, Jesuit Catholic University.
>> That's not good. That's not good. I did
not know that. Is this all just a
coincidence? She's a a baptized Catholic
who's wearing a Mounty's cross, who's
wearing a G on her finger, who's went to
Cath a Jesuit Catholic university.
Oh my goodness, it just keeps going.
>> I did not I did not know that.
>> Then she gives the speech that's 33
minutes long and in here she's saying,
"You have no idea what you have just
unleashed across this entire country and
this world."
>> Spell.
>> Yeah. inciting
a civil war.
>> Exactly.
>> You're going to put the
>> someone somewhere is going to say, "Hey,
that's me. She's speaking to me."
>> Yep.
>> You're You're going to put the widow of
the man who just died and and she's
saying
>> angry. Look at her face. It's it's it's
I get it. I get it. She's She's If if
you're
>> digging into this and you're seeing,
yeah, she's mad. She's upset because
she's upset with the left. I get it. If
that's the way you see it, no disrespect
there, but I mean, if you look at it
from another angle,
this is a woman who looks angry and now
you have all these sympathizers.
>> Yep.
>> And now these sympathizers are saying
that's the last straw,
>> right?
>> I'm I am through with messing around
with this these evil Democrats.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. This is a script she's reading.
It's all full of these trigger words and
spells and it's like you have no idea
what you just unleashed across the
country in this world. You have no idea.
The cries of this widow will echo around
the world like a battle cry.
>> She's ready. She is
>> queuing up people. She's
>> giving this is a power of suggestion.
This is how spells work. She's giving
She's giving information that people are
going to grab a hold of.
What if what if um we didn't know about
this whole situation and we we were
told, "Hey,
there's a Jesuit with a G ring, a
Maltese cross and he's behind a podium
on TV with an angry face telling
everyone that this is a battlecry and
you have no idea what you just
unleashed." Like that sounds like a
villain in a movie.
>> Yeah, it does.
>> But now replace it. both countries
>> with a beautiful widow of a man that
everybody admired and now oh no I can't
see it that way because my emotions are
so wrapped up that I'm blind
and I'm under the spell I'm under the
strong delusion
>> and and brother I and I'm on the same
page because I for me as well I followed
Kirk
>> I followed a lot of his stuff I I and
just for the record you know I I I
wanted to hear how did he respond to the
abortion argument how did he respond
respond to the LGBTs, to the DEI, and
all this kind of stuff. You want to know
that kind of stuff, and you're curious,
you know, maybe I can copy that or maybe
I can learn something from that. So,
after a while, you get emotionally
connected to these characters.
>> Yeah.
>> And if you're not careful, that
emotional connection will tear you
>> uh when they die, it'll tear you up.
It'll it'll take you to a place that you
didn't intend for it to go.
>> Well, what is deception?
>> And that's what's happening all over the
world. Deception is a lot of truth, a
little bit of error. It's that eyropper
of poison in that nice ice cold glass of
lemonade. You're not going to drink the
bottle of bleach, but you'll drink the
cyanide laced lemonade because it looks
so good. And so, yeah, there's going to
be a lot of truth out there. Ravi
Zacharias spoke a lot of truth, but he
was a hypocrite doing sexual things with
women. I used to love Alex Jones when I
first woke up in 2012 because he was
speaking the truth and he was reading
declassified documents and telling
people, "Wake up. This stuff's like it's
it's exposed. It's declassified. You can
read it yourself." And yet now I know
that he's a double agent. I don't trust
him either.
>> And so that's that's a person that I
would say was I was emotionally attached
to maybe at for a time. He was like, "My
dude, I couldn't wait to watch the next
Alex Jones video."
>> Right.
>> Yes.
>> Because he was speaking the truth.
and and he's still speaking truthful
things, but I don't trust him.
>> Right. Right. We need to be very careful
who we trust. We really really do. Who
we need to trust. What we need to trust
is the Bible. And that's just pretty
much it.
>> And if someone does not speak according
to the word,
>> that's right.
>> Then it's because there's no truth in
them,
>> no light in them. So, so
>> to continue on with what she's saying
here because dude, this is she's setting
it up and it's oh, it's so encrypted
with things. So, first she said, "You
have no idea what you unleash across
this world. This is the the cries of a
widow echo around the world like a
battle cry. You have no idea the fire
that you have ignited within this wife."
So,
>> okay, stop there. Stop there for one
second. Yeah,
>> it has been said about Charlie that he
is the spark and that she is the fire.
>> Oh, I never heard that.
>> And yes, he is the spark and she is the
fire.
>> So now what we have going on is
basically she's taking that torch and
she's moving forward to the next stage,
whatever it is that they're doing.
>> Whoa. I want to find that because it
helps me. Let's see. Charlie and Eric
Erica
Spark and Fire, you said.
>> Mhm.
>> Charlie was the spark. Here it is. Um,
>> pull it up. Pull that up.
>> Charlie was the spark. Erica is the
fire. Oh my goodness, dude. This is like
you just added another layer that I
didn't even know existed.
>> And and people are actually putting it
in here. Let's see. What are they saying
here? You have no idea the fire that you
have ignited within this wife. Okay,
>> this this is so deep now. This is so
deep now. Check this out because
>> so deep. This is actually what we're
talking about right now with all of this
fire and and the spark
>> and what is going on with her. This is
big big big. You do not understand how
powerful her voice is right now in the
world. She might be I mean you might
argue and say that she is the number one
most important voice at this moment in
time.
>> Oh yeah, I agree. Yeah. What did I say?
I said do you know where his studio is
based out of or where Turning Point
started?
>> Phoenix.
>> Phoenix. What is a phoenix?
It's the fire
>> a firebird. the fire bird that's rising
out of the ashes. All the occult is all
about this oraoris, the phoenix rising
out of the ashes. That's why it's on the
dollar bill. Dude, it they did it with
9/11. Dude, if you guys have not seen
the video about
>> it's it shows Trump on there with a
golden calf. I I'm about to show the
thumbnail, but you have to watch it
because that blew my mind. That was the
Holy Spirit totally leading because I
saw things that I'd never seen before. I
didn't understand all the symbolism.
Those towers were built to be destroyed.
It was a ritual.
9 and 11, all those numbers have a
significance. 11 means to build two
pillars, destroy them, and put back one
pillar. That's exactly what they did
with those towers. They they built two
towers. And you can It says you can do
it.
>> Amazing.
>> Yeah. It says you can do it physically
or metaphorically.
>> But they did it physically. They built
two towers
>> and then they destroyed it and now they
brought back one world tower
>> and that's all about Phoenix Rising.
>> But they they have been sharing this
symbolism for ages. I mean for decades
and decades before this actually took
place.
>> Oh yeah.
>> This was a planned thing.
>> Oh goatient people.
>> Exactly.
>> Because Satan's been around for
thousands of years.
>> So now she's talking about igniting a
fire. She's talking about igniting the
world on fire, right? That's what she's
saying.
>> Now, look at this. Burn, baby, burn.
Dude, this picture was actually taken.
>> Okay, when was this?
>> This is 2018.
And then, okay, so burn, baby, burn.
>> She's the He's the spark. She's the
fire. They live in Phoenix. She's
talking about you don't know what you've
just ignited. Burn the world.
>> Oh. Oh,
>> look what this says.
>> It's so symbolic. It's so symbolic,
brother.
>> Who coined the phrase set the world on
fire? The phrase set the world on fire
is attributed to
>> St.as
of Lo Lyola
>> of Lyola,
>> the founder of the Jesuit order. That
wouldn't mean that could be a huge
coincidence except that she went to a
Jesuit college
>> and she's wearing a Maltese cross and a
G on her finger
>> and she's saying all these trigger
words. Dude, this is more than a
coincidence.
>> Whenever you get this many coincidences,
you need to ask why.
>> Yep.
And so the phoenix because everything's
in phoenix right now in the occult the
in spiritual sense the phoenix
symbolizes resurrection immortality and
profound spiritual transformation.
This is all about bringing about new
world order. Or order out of chaos. It
says resurrection and rebirth
>> from the ashes
>> immortality transformation and renewal.
All of this is look
>> born again from the ashes.
>> It's all the same stuff.
>> She's she's right now she's calling to
burn the world down
>> so that we can build back order
out of chaos.
>> Okay. Now now hold now hold that
thought. Trump says I'm going to say it
again. Without a major event
>> where people pull together
>> Yeah. That's hard to bring the country
back to its unity.
>> Wow.
Wow. Dude, this is the the video I'm
talking about. If you guys have not seen
this, please watch it because it'll make
all this make so much more sense. Like
right now, you probably just think, "Oh
man, this guy's just reaching or
whatever." When you already see what has
been exposed in this video, it just
everything go falls into place. Um, and
then she goes into the spiritualism.
Charlie would he'll be there. He'll be
there in spirit. I know my husband is
still here. He's watching over us.
Spirit. This is necromancy. This is
spiritualism. The dead know nothing. The
dead rest in the grave until the
resurrection of Christ's return. And
when he blows that trumpet sound and the
the dust, the people of the dead that
are in the dust of the earth will
>> rise out of their graves.
And I and so I was looking at her
website and she's talking about midweek
rise up rising from the ashes spark
notes on. See, I didn't know anything
about this spark thing that's going on
with her, but all these terms about fire
and spark and rising from the ashes.
And I haven't heard anybody talk about
this
burn. It looks like a brand.
>> It looks like a
>> hor
almost like a tuning fork.
>> That's Yeah, you're right. Like I was I
was like, what is this little extended
thing on the end of this Omega symbol.
>> I thought it was an Omega symbol, but uh
yeah, maybe I don't want to jump into
that if I'm wrong about that because I
was looking at like
>> secret societies and esoteric
traditions. The omega symbol carries
multiple meanings. Basically,
it means the
the end and renewal. It's the phoenix
out of the ashes
because omega is end the last.
And then she says, "But most important
of all, if you aren't a member of a
church, I beg you to join one.
>> I beg you to join one." Look at this,
guys.
>> I beg you to join a church. And
>> And there's so many people I I don't
know about you, but I have been
contacted. My wife has been contacted
uh this week by people where we were
like what
>> because why and not even Christian
people I'm saying this is a revival
going around the world right now
>> right
>> people through this this Kirk effect
>> people are becoming con you are a
churchgoer or not no
>> whether you are a churchgoer or not
whether you're a Christian or not people
are be be feeling like that this one
lady said I was not a Christian I never
wanted any of that. But after the death
of Kirk, I felt drawn to my husband's
Bible.
>> This is the kind of stuff you're seeing.
>> Wow.
>> Yeah. So, I'm sure the Lord can work
with some of this as well. Don't get me
wrong. But
>> yeah,
>> general, uh, we got to be careful
>> because God can use anything to bring us
to the truth. But we have to go to the
source of truth. You have to go to God's
word. That's how he speaks to us. You
can't look to Charlie Kirk. You can't
look to Trump. You can't look to Kenneth
Copeland. all these people like,
man, somebody's name in here is called
Southern Baptist Mason.
>> Um,
so there was a a couple of strange
things that I found when I was looking
up their names. I I'm used to looking up
the names of people from movies and
stuff to see what the characters
represent and all that. And um, and here
I looked up define the name Charlie and
it means free man.
So,
Satan is all about
pushing his false liberty, right? You
see it in Transformers. They're saying
all sentient beings deserve liberty. We
just we have to kill that cube that
created us. Basically, that you have to
kill the creator to get liberty. There's
a movie called Free Guy with Ryan
Reynolds. He was in a game system. He
didn't realize it until he reached the
end of the, you know, the the invisible
wall. And it was all about breaking
free.
>> Um, and and to be lawless because he was
bound by rules.
>> The Matrix Truman Show, you're bound in
a system of rules, a perfect paradise,
but you want to be free from that.
>> Charlie means free. I also think it's
interesting that the word char means to
burn.
>> Oh, wow.
>> Char, lie. Okay, think about that. Char,
the burning lie. And then Kirk, what
does Kirk mean? A church or a place of
worship? What? Wait, we want to we want
to start a new lawless church.
That's what his name means.
>> The free man.
>> And And it's got char
>> char lie. A burning lying church. Dude,
>> we're gonna burn down the old system.
They use the the sound of of the of of
what things sound like to send messages.
It is it is very sophisticated, very
>> very dark.
>> So yeah, even if you think
>> char and lie is a stretch, it still
means the free man church, which is the
lawless church. And Jesus said many are
going to say, "Lord, Lord,
>> I wish that you were hot or cold, but
because you're lukewarm, I'm going to
vomit you out of your out of my mouth.
A lukewarm church, a lawless church is
one that believes in coexist and
tolerance and we're all, you know, we're
all children of God. Even if you
practice voodoo and you're a Buddhist,
we all believe in something. They're all
different languages to God. The Pope
said,
>> um, so Erica, his wife, means eternal
ruler. That's pretty interesting.
Eternal ruler, church. But remember her
last name used to be something
different. What was her last name? Fron.
Oh, what does it mean?
>> What does it mean? Free man.
What?
So her name literally meant eternal
ruler. The free man. Eternal ruler.
>> That's Lucifer.
He wants to be the ruler of lawlessness.
>> They come to free us. They're They're
here to free us from
>> That's right.
>> from the system.
>> What?
>> So, isn't it weird that her maiden name
means the same thing as his first name?
Free man. Is that a coincidence?
Are the two people who were martyrs
having the same birthday? Was that a
coincidence?
>> Uh, what about
>> names, by the way, are extremely
important for the occult. They're
extremely important. Take that very
seriously. You mentioned this girl for
those who don't know
>> the girl on the train. I say I I want to
challenge anyone to watch that video. I
didn't even want to watch it because
when I saw what it was about, I'm like,
I don't want to see that. But then my
curiosity got the best of me because I'm
like, is this a false flag or something?
There's no blood on her neck. You You
look at that. It shows both sides when
you look at both camera angles and you
make up your mind when somebody gets
jabbed three to five times and then
they're sitting there for 20 seconds,
fall out of their seat and the blood is
under their butt but not on their neck.
I got questions. When you conveniently
fall behind a metal wall and it looks
like a cup of blood just gets poured
over a step. I got questions. I believe
that if anyone watched that scene in a
movie, they would mock it and say that
was the fakest, cheesiest looking scene
I've ever seen. But because it's on the
news, we got to believe it, right? We
can't believe that we're being duped,
that we're being controlled by the
controllers that they're trying to
divide and conquer. And what was the
name of the or what was it called? The
Charlotte murder. Her name wasn't
Charlotte. It happened to Charlotte.
What do we got again? Char.
>> What does the word Charlotte mean? Free
woman.
Free man.
>> Wow,
>> dude. What are the What are the
>> Do you have her name on there?
>> I don't. I should get it.
>> You should have.
>> This was the guy.
>> You should look that up.
>> Tyler Robinson. I couldn't figure out
anything about his name.
>> Don't Don't jump Don't jump to Tyler
just yet. With uh with the Charlotte the
Ukrainian girl.
>> Oh, look her name. I
>> Yeah, look it up, please. Um we whether
you believe that u it was staged or not
or maybe she could have been a sacrifice
that's a possibility maybe you believe
she was a sacrifice maybe you believe
you know uh it was staged but whatever
the case is
>> that happened on 22
>> we can say is that they are exploiting
that one as well like I brought up
earlier um you see this young white girl
and these these black people all around.
This guy with tattoos and he looks very
rough and he's over here with a with a
knife. His last name is Brown. It's
almost like they are trying to
>> That's crazy.
>> speak to you. Think of it brown. Almost
like
>> become afraid of this.
>> Yeah.
>> And so it's doing more of that fear
putting fear in people and it's causing
you to be like h I'm afraid of those
people. Those people are scary to me.
So, I mean, I'm just telling you, it's
like they're using both of these deaths
>> on purpose
>> to further the divide. So, pay attention
to that whenever you see this uh this
this Hegelian dialectic.
>> So, I'm not seeing her last name mean
anything, but um her first name means
peace.
Peace and harmony. So, it's kind of like
>> Wait a second. There is more peace. Yes,
brown is killing the peace and harmony.
>> Brown is killing and destroying your
peace. That is that is
>> it's interesting that we have 205 people
in here. We've been going for two hours
and and just now we got like three
thumbs down and it was it about the girl
because that makes me almost want to
show you
the the video clip because it's just
like
just look at it, man. I'm not going to
do it for you. you you watch the video
clip and show me where is the blood on
her neck. Literally the place that got
attacked
um
has no blood and so I'm I'm only just
looking at what am I looking at? You
know, I'm asking questions because it
doesn't make sense to me and I don't
trust the media. Has nothing to do with
me against some girl. This is me not
trusting politics, the rulers of this
world, the mainstream media, the
propaganda.
That's what this is about.
>> Recognizing constant symbolism in
everything that happens. Recognizing
that this is a stage and that this is a
movie and that we're
>> Jesuit theater.
Tyler Robinson was 22 years old. And the
death of that girl on the train was on
August 22. Always 22, always 11, always
six. What I So, I don't know where
you're going with this, but something
that caught my attention was
um Tyler Robinson. Tyl Tyler Robinson.
The name Robinson means son of Robin,
which means nothing to me. But
what was the other event that just
happened? Another trans person shot up a
Catholic school was doing target
practice on Jesus and just happened to
write the manifesto, his manifesto on
the bullets.
>> Kyle, come on.
>> This is like a movie script.
>> Listen to how ridiculous that sounds.
Listen how ridiculous that sounds.
>> They said the same.
>> Yeah. He said the same thing with uh
with this too with this situation. He
they wrote the manifesto on the bullets.
>> His canister right on the bullet
canister or something like that.
>> What was the name of the shoot?
>> Only only it it
>> look I said who shot up the Catholic
school in Minneapolis? What was his
name? Where is it at? Minneapolis
shooter. What's his name?
>> Oh yeah, I remember this one.
>> Where's his name at?
This is um this is trying to send a
message.
>> Look at that. What does that say?
>> Robin.
>> What?
>> Interesting.
>> Wait, the shooter's name was Robin? What
was the shooter's name that just
Robinson?
I don't know, man. I know people are
just going to be What are the chances,
man? These these things happened a month
or two apart or something
and you got Robin and Robinson.
>> Yeah. And I and I just want to say
they're all connected. What they're
trying to do, I believe, because this is
Jesuit theater, that this whole life is
nothing but just
uh a theater that we're living in, a
matrix, if you will. They're trying to
instill the LGBT
as
uh uh dangerous, as deranged,
and the Christian needs to be afraid of
them. The same thing with with with the
the races.
Blacks need to be feel disrespected by
whites. Whites need to be afraid or feel
disrespect. It it's it's all the same
stuff over and over again on repeat.
It's just theater
>> because I I don't want to believe we're
duped. I don't want to believe that
everything's a lie. I don't want to
look at something and think that it's
fake or anything either. Um, this is a
bad video, but okay. So, there it is
under the seat. I'm looking at her neck.
Nothing. That's the side she was
attacked on. Um, somebody just said
something about left. There was another
view. You can watch the other view. same
thing. The other I have I have the
screenshots on my phone, but
um watch both views. I challenge you. I
challenge you.
I don't want to believe this stuff
either, man.
You saw everything we presented. I mean,
there's
number patterns,
hand signs, there's rings, there's
necklaces, there's blatant admissions of
being baptized Catholic in a Jesuit,
went to a Jesuit college,
talking to the camera, saying, "I want
to burn the world down."
I see an agenda happening. You know,
there's people saying like, you know,
why
people see that he was a Sabbathke
keeper, that he defended Christianity,
and they can't see how it plays into the
agenda. But Satan has to get both sides.
The dragon's going to deceive the whole
world, not the liberal left. There had
to be a hero. There had to be somebody,
somebody for the right to lift up and
idolize that was charismatic and said
things that they agree with
and then be taken out so that we would
be enraged and say, um, yeah, civil war
time
because it's divide and conquer.
And when there's chaos, that's what this
is really about.
>> Yeah. When there's chaos, that's when
we're willing to give up all our
freedoms. We give up all our freedoms
for peace and safety.
And that's where I I see all this
headed.
>> We may disagree on how it happened or
what happened
and I'm talking about everyone here,
>> right?
>> But one thing we can should be able to
see, I would say, is that yes, they are
unifying the country. Yes, this was the
uh crisis that they were looking for.
Yes, there is a divide taking place.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh there is a civil war that is going to
take place against
every
two-sided
uh polar opposite
situation
and these things are real.
Um, and and yes, uh, we are living in
the matrix, so to speak. This is Jesuit
theater. What we see on TV and on the
news is not real. It's not real. I mean,
you can tell that it's not real. There
are compilations of news anchors saying
the same things all over the world,
>> the same. It makes no sense for them to
repeat that stuff. Happened with COVID
>> happened with COVID. That stuff that
stuff I mean I have collections of
different articles and videos that I've
collected over the years. Stuff with
COVID. I mean, it's just like they're
mocking our stupidity really is
partially what one of the things they're
doing. Um, but they know they can get
away with this stuff because people like
you, people like me, we don't want to
believe this stuff is real because why
would we want to,
>> right?
>> It's sad.
>> Who wants to live in a world of lies,
man?
>> We want to live in a world of peace. We
want to live in a world of happiness.
But we we look around and we look at
this stuff and
>> this really is happening. And we're sad
to announce it. But what we're doing
here right now, Mikey and I, we're
announcing that something evil is coming
and they're exploiting this death. All
right? Whatever you believe about the
death, put that aside for a minute. They
are exploiting the death.
And it's not good what is happening
because our country
it's going downhill now from here on
out. I I believe personally that
this is a turning point for the USA.
>> Personally, I believe that that is a
um predictive programming. That's just a
personal conviction.
>> Um if if you understand what I mean by
that. But
>> oh yeah
>> this is a turning point for the United
States of America for the world because
goes America goes the world we all know
that so we are seeing
this is happening now so
that's all we're saying you don't have
to believe every detail you know but at
least open your eyes and admit those
things that cannot be denied
>> what do you think about this comment
right here if you can read
If you think Satan is trying to uplift
Christianity, you are a fool. Oh, 100%
he's trying to uplift Christianity. I
mean, that's the whole point of then
you'd have to deny the Bible verse that
talks about that Satan is going to be
transformed into an angel that
>> Paul said he's going to come from among
us.
>> Yeah.
>> Antichrist comes from among us. So yeah,
all throughout the Bible, you know that
God's people are going to uh wolf in
>> wolf and sheep clothing.
>> Sheep's clothing,
>> wheat and tears look the same concept.
>> Wheat and tears look the same.
>> They say the same things.
>> False Christ.
>> They all look the same.
>> False apostles, false disciples. I if
you don't understand all these Bible
verses that describe all these things,
if you don't understand that Antichrist
is actually in the place of Christ,
>> right?
>> Yeah.
>> Then you aren't going to understand,
you're not going to accept that Satan is
going to uplift Christianity. Yes, it is
true that God can use that for a time,
but after you get to a
>> because God's dealing with us till the
end, till he returns, he'll use
anything.
>> He deals with deception. He deals with
deception all day long. He deals with
people who are in cults. He deals with
people who have been deeply deceived. He
can deal with deception. So he can save
people out of any level of deception.
>> I'm wonder
this person says there is no the
antichrist. We never said anything about
the antichrist. There are many
antichrist and um like a big portion of
that is the Catholic Church which
proclaims to be Christians. So for you
to say why would Satan lift up
Christianity? Why do we have the
Catholic Church?
I mean, that's a prime example right
there. Why do we have Mormonism? The the
Church of Jesus of Latter-day Saints,
the Church of Jesus Christ. Like, if you
were going to find a church and you're
looking, I want to I worship Jesus.
Which church I'm going to go to? They
actually have Jesus in the title. I'm
going to go to that church. But they
have a false Christ. What about
newagers? Newagers talk to Jesus 101.
He's one of their many ascended masters.
If you think that just because you
believe in Jesus that that's
Christianity, that's that's not there.
Which Jesus? There's many of them. The
the Jehovah's Witness Jesus, the Mormon
Jesus, the New Age Jesus, the Buddhist
Jesus,
>> the Catholic Jesus.
So, yeah, to I mean, you have to be very
careful to think that Satan is not going
to lift up Christianity.
It's it's just like this kid that Jesus
>> was on ketamine. He was in a hospital
and he's on drugs and he had the same
experience that everyone has on
ketamine. They go out of their body.
They see angelic beings. They see Jesus.
They talk to dead people. I can give you
testimony after testimony after
testimony. I've put it on this channel
already. And yet everybody was so
emotionally driven by this little boy
crying saying he saw his dead dad in
Jesus. That is a false Christ. The dead
know nothing. You're talking to the dead
as necromancy,
but Christians have lost all
discernment.
>> At that point, you're going to have so
much emotional connection to that when
you see your dead mom walking down the
hallway.
>> Yeah.
>> And she says,
>> "My son, I have missed you and I love
you."
>> And she talks the way she talks. She
walks the way she walked. You are so
convinced that she is your mother.
You're going to be so emotionally
connected that your heart will deceive
you. Don't trust your heart. It will
betray you.
>> Yeah.
>> It says Satan hates Jesus. He doesn't
want people reading what Jesus said.
Dude, I can show you I can show you new
age books that
>> 90% of the book is the Bible.
>> Law of attraction, manifestation, the
secret, all they're using scripture all
the time.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. Look at the occult. They have the
Bible up there. Whatever your culture
is, they have your the Quran, the Bible.
>> You get a Bible when you join the
Masons.
>> I mean, come on. We're we're we don't
know Jesus's words right now. We're in a
we're in a uh a crisis. Our country
doesn't know Jesus. And we have 15
Bibles in every house.
>> That's right.
>> We don't even know his words. We don't
open up the Bible and read them.
Otherwise, we wouldn't be saying the
things we're saying,
>> right? We listen to We have itching
ears. We don't want the truth. We
listen. That's another another verse in
the Bible.
>> I want to hear what I want to hear.
>> Yeah. Another verse in the Bible.
>> Listen, smooth things to me.
>> They will not heed sound doctrine
because they're listening to things that
that itch their ears. That's saying they
are going to church. They're listening
to a pastor, but he's not teaching the
truth. He's saying things like Joe
Ostein like, "Oh, Jesus loves you and
you're rich and beautiful and
>> just smile and everything's good." No,
you're going to die for the truth.
>> Get it.
>> Yep.
>> Exactly.
>> Oh, man.
>> So, we got to be very careful. That is a
big time deception.
>> Yeah, man.
>> Think that you can just do whatever,
believe whatever, and then you're set.
You got to be sanctified by the words of
Christ. His words have to go inside of
you. You have to eat them spiritually,
figuratively. You eat them. You become
them. They change you.
That's how it works. If you don't know
his word, if it's not hiding in your
heart, you're going to be lost.
>> Yeah.
Buy a show of thumbs up and thumbs down.
Let us know what you think.
I like I said this was this was just to
look at patterns look at evidence
because we don't want to be ignorant.
You know the Bible says do not be
ignorant of his devices. If we just go
through life thinking that the TV said
it must be real. We are in big trouble.
And um
you know God had to wake me up in
December 2011. I never saw the world
like this man. I lived in a
weed, alcohol, fornication every day,
all day, every day. That was my life.
>> And uh I just thought, you know, the
world is fun and there's nothing going
on in it. No deception behind the
scenes. And God woke me up in an
instant, December 2011, and I can't
unsee what he's shown me. And it's now
2025.
And uh I just refuse to walk through
this life blind anymore. That's what the
Bible says. this the god of this world
who Satan has blinded the minds of the
unbelievers
and and they're going to buy into a
strong delusion. There's all these
things about that there is deception in
our world and that we need to be
watching lest we fall prey to those
traps.
So
that's all I got, man.
>> So much so much important information to
cover.
Yeah.
>> A lot of that is very important. We need
to understand these things because we're
we're entering into a turning point for
sure.
>> Well, you prayed us in. I'll pray us
out.
All right. Lord, Father in heaven, we
just thank you so much for truth. We
thank you for your word. We thank you
for prophecy. We thank you for giving us
those who ask for it um discernment and
the gift of your Holy Spirit and
a lot of things that are happening in
this world we we wish weren't happening.
But we know that we're living in the
last days. We know that much deception
is coming because that's the first
warning you gave when people asked what
are the signs of your coming. He said,
"Do not be deceived that there'll be
many false prophets and and uh all these
things that are coming upon the world
before you come." And so the good news
is is that you are coming soon.
And uh the the not so good news is that
there's going to be a lot of bad things
happening. But Lord, I just pray that
you would be with us, conform us,
transform us, renew our minds,
mold us into your character so that we
can be shining lights in this dark world
so that we can help reach people in
these times of great deception.
And Lord, help us to be ready for your
soon return. And help us to not fall for
the deceptive things that are coming.
And Lord, you never send truth to offend
or to trigger, but the truth will set us
free. And Lord, like we said, no matter
what you believe about this situation,
we see where things are are going, where
the direction of uh the rulers of this
world are taking things, and they're
using
crisises to um
to make those things happen. So Lord, I
thank you for everybody that's here who
chose to be here when they could have
been anywhere else. I just pray that you
would bless each and every one of us and
help us to
just prepare people for your soon return
in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Well, thank you so much for coming on,
man. I know there was uh some technical
difficulties at the beginning, but man,
it worked out. Even at a even with a
late live, we had up to over 200 people
in here. So that's awesome.
>> That's good. Is that a pretty good uh
pretty good showing?
>> Yeah, usually it's
90s, something like that. Just depends
on what the topic is.
>> Yeah,
>> it's held held at 200.
>> Yeah, man. Well, do you have uh any kind
do you have a ministry or anything you
want to promote?
>> Yeah. Yeah, actually promote the uh
Advent Age uh YouTube channel.
>> Advent Age's YouTube channel.
>> Pull that up.
>> Yeah. Pull that up.
>> We are just starting off. We don't even
have a thousand followers yet. So, if
you'd like to follow us, we would love
for you to do that. Advent Age
Missions,
please.
>> Yeah. Advent Age Missions,
>> my wife and I. Uhu. So these are videos
from um camp meetings that you actually
host.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes.
>> Oh, that's awesome. Yeah. So you guys
are located in Alabama.
>> Alabama. Haleyville, Alabama. Yes. We do
camp meetings. We bring people. We do
revival, campouts, do all kinds of
different things.
>> You've had some big speakers there, man.
You've had Brad from Strange Normal.
You've had
>> um Scott Ritz from Trip. Yep, I've been
there.
>> Coming back.
>> Scott Ritzmas, Scotty
Meyer from Little Light,
>> Christian Bard Doll.
>> Yeah, man. So, yeah. Check out
>> Check out Advent.
[Music]
>> Nice.
>> Yes. Yes. My wife does a lot of the
shorts.
>> Oh, that's awesome.
>> And th those are the those
>> This one was cool. They lied to you
about hell. I love that one.
>> Which one?
>> Yeah.
>> Lied to you about
>> Here we go.
>> Awesome, man. Oh, dude. That's what's
up.
[Music]
>> Well, man, thanks for for joining this.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Going almost two and a half hours and
there's a lot of information and you you
brought a lot of good stuff, man. Thanks
for
>> Praise God.
>> Thanks for your input.
>> I enjoyed it. I enjoyed it. I'd love to
do it again. Yeah, we'll have to do it
again sometime.
>> All right, man. Well, we'll stick around
on there and I'll I'll talk to you in a
second.
>> All right, sounds good.
>> Thank you guys for being a part of this.
If this was eye opening to you, please
give it a thumbs up. It really helps get
this video out into the algorithm. If
you know somebody that needs to see
this, please share it with them. And if
you're not a subscriber, click
subscribe. Click that notification bell
so you don't miss another video. We come
out with at least a video a week, at
least one or two. We go live all the
time on deep dive topics like this. If
you want to support this ministry, you
can do so by going to candidruth.org. We
got cash app, Vinmo, Zel, PayPal. We
even got Patreon. We are a self or I
don't know what it's called,
donationbased ministry. And we cannot do
this without you guys. If you guys have
been given to us, we see you. We love
you. We thank you. We cannot do this
without you. If you guys like t-shirts,
we got some cool t-shirts on the
website. We get about $5 commission on
each of those. And if it takes a long
time, I'm sorry, that's Teespring. They
do take a long time. But we thank you
guys and we love you and we'll see you
next time on Candid Truth.